【音楽】 You know what I started doing during the day is watching Deal or No Deal. Remember that show? Deal or No Deal. Is that the one worth, let's like a Planko machine? Open the Knoosh. No, I'm not sure. Remind me what happens. So the library's all ran out of books.
【音乐】你知道我白天开始做什么了吗？我在看《Deal or No Deal》。还记得那个节目吗？《Deal or No Deal》。是那个像弹珠机一样的节目吗？打开那个箱子。不，我不确定。提醒我一下发生了什么。图书馆的书都借光了。
And so you found yourself where the few extra hours are all right. No, like I'll have it. Suit case one. So this is on a game show network or something? Yes, it's on Game Show Network. That's exactly right. Right. So you're just crushing great ideas during the day and then doing theater at night?
所以你发现自己多了几个小时的空闲时间，这挺好的。不，我会看的。一号手提箱。所以这是在游戏节目频道还是什么地方播的？是的，是在游戏节目频道。没错，就是这样。所以你白天就在那儿疯狂看这些精彩节目，晚上去演戏？
No, I can't text and type because I want to say my hands because I play piano in the show. And so I watch some games like while I have my breakfast. So I watch Steel and other. Remember that show? Yeah, of course. What does breakfast look like I watched you all another. Remember that show? Yeah, of course. What does breakfast look like these days
不，我不能一边发短信一边打字，因为我想保护我的手，因为我在演出里要弹钢琴。所以我吃早餐的时候会看一些游戏节目。所以我看《Deal or No Deal》之类的。还记得那个节目吗？当然记得。最近早餐都吃什么？
right now when you're in the rush? Let me guess. Jason, go first. It's eggs Benedict, because that's a breakfast with a sauce. And it needs to be a sauce on every meal. Okay, let me have a guess. Yeah.
现在你这么忙的时候？让我猜猜。Jason，你先来。是班尼迪克蛋，因为那是带酱汁的早餐。每一顿饭都需要有酱汁。好吧，让我猜猜。是的。
It's kind of like a sausage muffin thing, but instead of, like instead of like a English muffin on the sides or donuts. And cut in half like a bagel, like a bagel. Yeah. And then, and this, by the way, that's amazing. And the sausage is just loose good and plenty, you know, the look at liquorice. Instead of, yeah, at a restaurant, instead of like that pepper grinder, they go good in plenty. And they just squeeze it out.
有点像香肠松饼之类的东西，但不是那种英式松饼，而是甜甜圈。像百吉饼一样切成两半。对，像百吉饼。然后，顺便说一下，这太棒了。香肠就是那种松散的，还有Good & Plenty糖果，你知道那种甘草糖吗？在餐厅里，他们不用胡椒研磨器，而是用Good & Plenty。他们直接把它挤出来。
Shana, remember that huge, Shana, remember that photo of you and me in Scotty with that huge pepper grinder where you stand, boom, and the guy came over, you know, they come over, they go, like, would you like to know more about, I can't, I know, Jason, the European vacations anymore with you guys. But that That was only that was the second European trip we did. So anyway, so Sean, and the guy comes up, you know, they come. Who is your date? Will. Who was my date? What? It doesn't matter. I could have been your date.
Shana，还记得那张你和我还有Scotty的照片吗？那个巨大的胡椒研磨器，你站在那儿，砰的一声，那家伙走过来，你知道他们会走过来问：“你想了解更多关于……”我不知道，Jason，我再也不能和你们去欧洲度假了。但那是我们第二次欧洲之旅。总之，Shana，那家伙走过来，你知道他们会来。谁是你的约会对象？Will。谁是我的约会对象？什么？没关系。我本来可以是你的约会对象。
We don't need to get into. Every time we mentioned somebody now in the podcast, that person's like, I got 30 phone calls. I know. They're like, so so anyway, you know, the guy comes up and they go, you want some fresh pepper and they go, yeah, let's get some fresh pepper Give us a Turkish accent. Well, and this guy, nope, in this guy You think I want to have to write a fucking your mystery guest is laughing a note Sepology that I got a post mic is hot is some male I got a post on my Instagram a note Sepology because you prompted me to do an accent of the guy was my server in Istanbul. No, thank you me to do an accident of the guy was my server in Istanbul. No, thank you. So anyway, stop reading. When he goes, would you like some pepper? And I'm not, Sean, tell me, right, I'm
我们不需要深究。现在每次我们在播客里提到某个人，那个人就会说，我接到了30个电话。我知道。他们会说，总之，那家伙走过来问：“你需要新鲜胡椒吗？”然后他们说：“好，来点新鲜胡椒。”给我们来个土耳其口音。好吧，这家伙，不，这家伙……你以为我想写一份该死的道歉信吗？我的麦克风很烫，我得在Instagram上发一份道歉信，因为你让我模仿那个在伊斯坦布尔当服务员的家伙。不，谢谢。总之，别读了。当他说“你需要胡椒吗”，我不是在夸张，Shana，胡椒瓶有四英尺高。两个家伙出来扶着它。两个家伙扶着它。
not exaggerating. The pepper shaker was four feet lower. And two guys come out to hold it. And two guys told it. Yeah. That sounds like my, my, my, my, my big, bonge ears back in my early 20s. Yeah. That used to be on my dating profile, takes two guys to hold it. Listen, I have a... Oh, rock, rock, rock, rock, rock. All right, so your guest is still laughing. I love that. That's a good sign.
听起来像我20岁出头时那会儿。是的。那曾经是我的约会资料，写着“需要两个人才能扶住”。听着，我有一个……哦，摇滚，摇滚，摇滚。好吧，你的嘉宾还在笑。我喜欢这个，这是个好兆头。
It's a good sign. Wait, but you guys, I texted you one of those comments, did I text you both? The comment was like a week ago and somebody wrote about my show. They said, didn't you get that, Jay? The fat suit. Yeah, another fucking fat suit, I think.
这是个好兆头。等等，你们俩，我给你们发过那条评论吗？我给你们俩都发了吗？那条评论大概是一周前写的，有人写了关于我的节目。他们说，Jay，你没穿那件胖子装吗？是的，又是该死的胖子装，我想。
Wait, what, what, what, what, what? Somebody made a comment that Sean is wearing a fat suit and his, the, and his, no, somebody asked me on my Instagram or somewhere on Twitter, I don't remember. And it was Sean, did they, is that, is the outfit that they put you in supposed to make you look bigger, which is, you know, code for a fatter? Right. And it's just, I'm just fucking fat.
等等，什么，什么，什么？有人评论说Sean穿了胖子装，而且他的……不，有人在我的Instagram或者Twitter上问我，我不记得了。那是Sean，他们给你穿的那套衣服是为了让你看起来更胖吗？也就是“更肥”的代名词。对，而我其实就是他妈的胖。
And tell him what your friend said, you should say, no, it's supposed to make me look thinner. Why? By the way, Sean, you reminded me. I was watching, I was, I was seeing that your dating profile reminded me I was watching alone. That show, right? And it reminded me of something that they say in that all the time, which
告诉他你朋友是怎么说的，你应该说：“不，它是为了让我看起来更瘦。”为什么？顺便说一下，Sean，你提醒了我。我当时在看《Alone》那个节目，对吧？它让我想起了他们在节目里一直说的一句话，
is also in your daily profit, which is, hey, bear. Hey, bear. Hey, bear. No, what's up, bear? No, will, you know, the shameless plug here, you know. I know you have your new show. Yeah, have you not watched out last year? Oh, no, I want to see that.
那句话也出现在你的约会资料里，就是：“嘿，熊。嘿，熊。嘿，熊。”不，怎么了，熊？不，Will，你知道，这里有个无耻的植入广告。我知道你有新节目了。是的，你去年没看吗？哦，不，我想看那个。
I haven't seen it yet. I don't have, I know I'm going to watch it. Sean, sounds like you've got time on your hands, maybe instead of doing no deal. No, no, no, no. Are you kidding, dude? There's 11 seasons of deal, there no deal. You gotta get through.
我还没看。我知道我会看的。Sean，听起来你很有空啊，也许可以不用看《Deal or No Deal》了。不，不，不，不。你在开玩笑吗，伙计？《Deal or No Deal》有11季呢。你得看完。
What was for breakfast, by the way? I had, yesterday I had a egg cheese. We don't need the full week. The cheese egg and a cheese egg and bacon bagel. And then today I did good. I did yogurt with grape nuts and blueberries. And a banana and a little bit of a candy bar. God, there's some.
顺便问一下，早餐吃了什么？昨天我吃了鸡蛋奶酪。我们不需要知道整个星期的菜单。奶酪鸡蛋和培根百吉饼。今天我吃得不错。我吃了酸奶配葡萄干、蓝莓、香蕉，还有一点糖果棒。天哪，有些……
Wait, was the candy bar like a fun dip for the yogurt? No, it was a payday. You called that the equalizer, right? Just to cancel out everything else. Time for the equalizer. Half of a payday. You called that the equalizer, right? Just to cancel out everything else. Time for the equalizer. Half of it, payday. Hey, listen, better with you. You want to talk about a payday?
等等，糖果棒是像蘸酸奶的蘸酱吗？不，是Payday糖果棒。你管那叫“平衡器”，对吧？只是为了抵消其他所有东西。是时候用平衡器了。半个Payday。你管那叫“平衡器”，对吧？只是为了抵消其他所有东西。是时候用平衡器了。半个Payday。嘿，听着，和你在一起。你想谈谈Payday吗？
Our guests. Segway, Segway, Segway. Our guests. Let me just say this. They've sold more than 100 million records worldwide. Wait a minute. 54 songs in the UK singles chart, 17 top 10 albums in the UK chart. If I name a song, you're going to, I don't know, you're going to immediately guess.
我们的嘉宾。转场，转场，转场。我们的嘉宾。让我这么说吧。他们在全球卖出了超过1亿张唱片。等等。英国单曲榜上有54首歌，英国专辑榜上有17张前十名专辑。如果我说出一个歌名，你肯定会……我不知道，你肯定会立刻猜到。
They're incredibly, incredibly talented guys who have been just such a huge part of the music scene for so long. I don't want to say so many years to them, they're going to be bummed out and be like, what, that makes us old. But I will say this, we are all legitimate fans of theirs. None more than Sean and I, Sean and me, Sean and I have discussed these guys all the time. It's Martin Gore and Dave Goss from The Peshmo. Are you fucking kidding me?
他们是非常、非常有才华的人，在音乐界活跃了这么久。我不想对他们说“这么多年”，他们会感到沮丧，觉得“这让我们变老了”。但我会说，我们都是他们真正的粉丝。没有人比Sean和我更狂热了，Sean和我一直在讨论这些人。他们就是来自Depeche Mode的Martin Gore和Dave Gahan。你在开玩笑吧？
Wow. This is fucking crazy. A real, this is a delicious fucking parade. This is like, I can, I'm ready. real shit fucking whole this is like i can i can i can i can i can i can hang on david uh... david martin you should know nice to meet you both you're
哇。这太疯狂了。这真是一场美妙的游行。这就像，我可以，我准备好了。这真是太棒了，我简直……等等，David，Martin，很高兴见到你们俩。你们……
such an honor thank you shannon i when i knew that and we've been sort of trying to work this out to get you guys on here and shannon i talk about you guys all the time and we we've talked about your music we talk about your songs and about shannon you remember about a month ago we were talking about you guys on here. And Sean and I talk about you guys all the time. And we talk about your music, we talk about your songs. And Sean, do you remember about a month ago when we were talking about you guys
真是太荣幸了，谢谢。Shana和我，当我得知……我们一直在努力促成你们来这里，Shana和我一直在谈论你们。我们谈论你们的音乐，谈论你们的歌。Shana，你还记得大约一个月前我们在这里谈论你们吗？Sean和我一直在谈论你们。我们谈论你们的音乐，谈论你们的歌。Sean，你还记得大约一个月前我们谈论你们的时候吗？
and we were going to, and I knew that it was gonna happen. And it took, it was one of the worst, it was the hardest I've ever had to work to keep a secret. Oh, you knew. It was the new Sean when we had that conversation. Oh my God. You guys, I'm freaking out. I have 17,000 things to say to you.
我们当时打算……我知道这会发生的。这是我做过的最难保守的秘密之一。哦，你知道。Sean当时就在那儿，当我们进行那次谈话时。天哪。伙计们，我快疯了。我有17000件事想对你们说。
Oh, we got time, Sean. We go nothing but time, actually. You said we have nothing but time, of course, they me to go, it's just a question of time. I know every word to every song. Every word to every song. This is so wild. And I have to do this for you guys, because...
哦，我们有时间，Sean。我们有的是时间，事实上。你说我们有的是时间，当然，他们让我去……这只是时间问题。我记得每一首歌的每一个字。每一首歌的每一个字。这太疯狂了。我必须为你们做这件事，因为……
Okay, so I'm going to start out with this. Martin... I've never seen Johnis not excited., okay, so I'm gonna start out with this. Martin, I've never seen Thomas not excited. This is fun. I'm freaking out. So Martin, you came to a taping of Willing Grace. That is true. I did.
好吧，我要从这个开始。Martin……我从没见过Sean这么兴奋。好吧，我要从这个开始。Martin，我从没见过Sean这么兴奋。这太有趣了。我快疯了。所以Martin，你参加了《Will & Grace》的录制。那是真的。我参加了。
Yes. And went way, way, way. What if he didn't remember that? I've been trying to keep that quiet for years. That's a fun. That's a news out. That's a day, I love it. So wait, so you came to a taping of Will and Grace
是的，而且……等等，等等，等等。如果他不记得了怎么办？我多年来一直试图保持低调。这很有趣。这是个新闻。这是个好日子，我喜欢。等等，所以你参加了《Will & Grace》的录制，
and somebody whispered in my mirror, you're Martin Gors in the audience. I'm like, what are you talking about, Martin Gors in the audience? What are you, he's, the passion on is like my life. What are you talking about? And then you were there with your wife
有人在我耳边低语：“Martin Gore在观众席里。”我说：“你在说什么？Martin Gore在观众席里？你在说什么？Depeche Mode就像我的生命一样。你在说什么？”然后你和你的妻子，
and your wife's friends or something like that. And then you asked, let's go out to grab from Fission Chips at the standard hotel on Sons of Boulevard. And I was like, oh my God, I'm gonna go out out with fish and chips. I've never had fish and chips. This is so exciting. So we go out for fish.
还有你妻子的朋友们之类的在一起。然后你问：“我们出去在日落大道的Standard酒店吃炸鱼薯条吧。”我当时想：“天哪，我要去吃炸鱼薯条了。”我从来没吃过炸鱼薯条。这太令人兴奋了。所以我们去吃炸鱼薯条。
And I'm walking down the street with you, which was so surreal to me. And I did this bit for you, which is waiting for the night off of Violator. And I'll do it for you now, which is... ...wait, wait for it. It will cut out the lock bar. Because this is what I used to do in college. There it comes. This is it. This is coming up.
我和你走在街上，这对我来说太超现实了。我为你表演了一段，就是《Violator》专辑里的《Waiting for the Night》。我现在就为你表演，就是……等等，等等，等着看。它会……因为这就是我大学时常做的。它来了。就是这个。它要来了。
The family will come. And I wrote my fucking senior thesis paper on this song. Come on, college. Here we go. Here we go. This is it. I can see your thesis paper on this song. Come on, college. Oh, swear to God. Here we go. Here we go, this is it. Be taking up the glasses. Listen.
家人会来的。我把我该死的毕业论文写在了这首歌上。来吧，大学。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。就是这个。我能看到你的毕业论文写在这首歌上。来吧，大学。哦，发誓。我们开始吧。我们开始吧，就是这个。摘下眼镜。听着。
Oh. I'm like that sounded like a bug, but now that you have given me that visual, and we perform that song every night, I will be thinking of you. Time to re-shoot the video. So Dave and Martin, how do you guys respond to Ashahn Hayes is just boiled your music down to something like a bug?
哦。我当时觉得那听起来像个虫子，但现在你给了我那个画面，而且我们每晚都表演那首歌，我会想起你的。是时候重拍那个视频了。所以Dave和Martin，你们怎么回应Sean Hayes把你们的音乐简化成某种像虫子的东西？
Oh my God, this is unbelievable. Again, not to belabor, but we talk about you guys all the time, such massive fans of your music and have been all the way through. And we've had the good fortune of having bands on the show who have been played important parts of our lives. But there are a few bands like you guys who have been there consistently over time. And that is also the mark of real greatness, is showing consistency over time. And you're still doing it. And so I kind of want to go back to the very beginning, if I may, and not to bore you,
天哪，这太不可思议了。再说一次，不是要啰嗦，但我们一直在谈论你们，我们是你们音乐的超级粉丝，一直都是。我们很幸运能请到在我们的生活中扮演过重要角色的乐队来到节目中。但像你们这样长期保持一致的乐队并不多。这也是真正伟大的标志，就是长期保持一致。而且你们还在继续。所以我很想回到最初，如果可以的话，不是要让你们感到无聊，
because we're so interested to hear about how the Pesh Mode came to be, or in each one of you, I know that you each have a different journey as how you became part of the Pesh mode came to be and each one of you, I know that you each have a different journey as how you became part of the Pesh mode. And I'd love to sort of hear from you guys what that, what that process was. Shaking right now. Well, Vince and Andy really started the whole thing. They had a, like, a little ban going. And I bought a synthesizer.
因为我们非常想听听Depeche Mode是如何形成的，或者你们每个人，我知道你们每个人加入Depeche Mode的旅程都不同。我很想听听你们讲述那个过程。我现在在发抖。嗯，Vince和Andy确实开始了这一切。他们有一个小乐队。我买了一台合成器。
So that kind of like got me in the band. Yeah. By the way, that's a very common, that by the way, that's a very common theme. We interviewed a bunch of bands and they're always like, I had a guitar, I had a camera, or whatever, right? Well, there's a lot to do with that because when what we found out was, well, elaborate on this, but you didn't need the amp anymore and you didn't need to, you could just de-eye straight into a P-A system, carried a little synth
所以这让我加入了乐队。是的。顺便说一下，这是一个非常普遍的主题。我们采访过很多乐队，他们总是说：“我有一把吉他，我有一台相机，或者其他什么，对吧？”嗯，这和那个有很大关系，因为我们发现的是……嗯，详细说说这个，但你不再需要放大器了，你也不需要……你可以直接接入扩声系统，带着一个小合成器，
under your arm pretty much to a gig and show up with our little drum machine and three synths and kind of teetering on some beer crates in a pub or whatever, as I stands and we could play, you know. And Dave, did you know these guys, when they first started, or did you meet them a little bit later? I, there was sort of infamous in the town that we grew up in for other things,
几乎可以夹在腋下就去演出，带着我们的小鼓机和三个合成器，在酒吧的啤酒箱上摇摇晃晃地站着，这就是我们的支架，我们就能演奏了。Dave，你刚开始认识他们的时候，还是后来才认识的？我在我们长大的那个镇上，他们因为其他事情而臭名昭著，
but I did not really run in the same circles, but it was a good thing for me, because they sort of, you know, it gave me suddenly a focus that I had something to kind of grab hold of and maybe it was a way out of the town that we grew up in. And they, yeah, I think how we met properly was I was sort of hanging out with another band right, Mark, and yeah, yeah, and we were just rehearsing
但我并没有真正进入同一个圈子，但这对我来说是件好事，因为它给了我一个焦点，让我有东西可以抓住，也许这是离开我们长大的那个镇的一种方式。而且他们……是的，我想我们正式认识是因为我当时和另一个乐队混在一起，对吧，Martin？是的，是的，我们当时在同一个空间排练，
in the same space and one evening. I knew Vince a bit, we were singing, sort of jamming together the song here, I was a barwiss song. And Vince heard me sing in the song supposedly the story goes and asked me to join his band which was then a different band which Martin was in With what's the name of that band composition of sound? What an amazing name for sure Cars cars for sure Like all MD you know,
一天晚上。我认识Vince一点，我们在唱歌，算是即兴合唱那首歌，我当时是伴唱。Vince听到了我唱歌，故事就是这样，他问我是否愿意加入他的乐队，那当时是另一个乐队，Martin也在里面。那个乐队叫什么名字？Composition of Sound？真是个惊人的名字。Cars，Cars，肯定。就像所有MD一样，你知道，
they would try to be like, oh, MD, it's okay. But meanwhile, it sounds like a manual that you find in a music story. I was like, that's gotta go. And I got such a, I got a better name, Dipeshmo, which everybody also went like, what? Like, I know that. And we, but let's talk about that
他们会试图表现得像，“哦，MD，没关系。”但与此同时，它听起来像你在音乐商店里找到的说明书。我说：“那必须得改。”我起了一个更好的名字，Depeche Mode，每个人也都问：“什么？像那个？”我知道。但是，让我们谈谈那个，
because in French, it's fast fashion. So why, why, why fast fashion? I tell you this story. Look, I was, I was at a, you sort of art college in, as we were at one point. And I was doing a fashion course there. And there was this, this, there was magazines there. I think, I think it was something like we had a gig somewhere. We had to kind of,
因为在法语里，它是“快时尚”。所以为什么，为什么，为什么是“快时尚”？我给你们讲这个故事。看，我当时在艺术学院，我们当时在那个阶段。我在那里上时装课。那里有杂志。我想，我想是因为我们在某个地方有演出。我们当时在考虑改名字。我们有一个小酒吧演出要来，这是改名字的时刻。所以应该叫什么？我看到了这本杂志。这是一本法语杂志，一本法语时尚杂志放在那里。当时，我根本不知道它是什么意思，
we were thinking about changing a name. We had a little pub gig coming up and this was the moment to change the name. So what should it be? And I saw this magazine. It was a French sort of magazine, a French fashion magazine line there. At the moment, I had no idea what it meant
或者其他什么，我只是把它读了出来。在电话里对某人说：“哦，我们是Depeche Mode。”那是个奇怪的夜晚。就像，是的，确实是。这是否给你们带来了更大的压力，让你们去想出华丽的服装？不，我们当时已经在尝试了。
or anything, I just read it out. Over the phone to somebody, I said, oh, we're in depression mode. That's a weird night. That's like, yeah, it is. Did it put more pressure on you guys to come up with fancy outfits? No, we were already trying that.
那时候大部分都是自制的，你知道，所以，你知道，那会是一双足球袜，膝盖拉到膝盖处，配上剪短的裤子，把它们塞进去。还有一些拖鞋……John完全在开玩笑。所以告诉我，你们组建了，Dave，你加入了，然后你们命名它，你们称自己为Depeche Mode。你们开始演出。是的。
Most of them homemade at that point, you know, so, you know, it would be, it would be a pair of football socks with like, the knees, pulled up to the knees with some cut-offs to the knees and took them in. And some house slippers that were coming. John is fully around. So tell me, so you guys formed, Dave, so you join and then you name it and you guys call yourself to Pesh mode. You start doing gigs. Yeah.
在你们的第一张唱片《Speak & Spell》之前有多少场演出？是的。是的。所以每一首歌的每一个字。是的。我的意思是，《Speak & Spell》。是的。
How many before you your first record is a speaking spell. Yeah. Yeah. And yeah. So everywhere to every song. Yeah. I mean, speaking spell. Yeah.
我想过一会儿再深入探讨那个，以及Vince Clarke，但在你们发行《Speak & Spell》之前，你们是怎么得到那份唱片合约的？你们在做什么？你们在哪里表演？是的。我们演奏了那张唱片里的大部分歌，对吧，Martin？而且，大部分是Vince Clarke的歌。
And I want to get into that in a second and into to to Vince Clark and but what was before you release speaking spell, how does that come about that you guys get that record deal? Like, what are you doing? Where are you performing? Yeah. We were playing most of the songs from that record, right, my like, and, we've mostly Vince Clark songs.
而且，这确实是唯一一张专辑，因为Vince在专辑发行后立即离开了。他在那上面唱歌了吗？在它发行之前。哦，在专辑发行后立即。他在那上面唱歌了吗？在它发行之前。哦，真的吗？在它之前。是的。但他在那张唱片上也唱歌了，是的。嗯，我们……我们一起唱。这就像某种三部曲和声的东西。所以，我想我们追求的是海滩男孩遇见雷蒙斯那种风格。但是，嗯，嗯，嗯，雷蒙斯的速度和海滩男孩的和声，我想那是……
And it was, it's really the one album that, because Vince left immediately, often albums released. And did he sing on that? Before it was released. Oh, immediately after the album was released. And did he say, he's saying on that? Before it was released. Oh really? Before it was. Yeah. But he's saying on that record too, yeah. Well, we, we, we sang together. It was like sort of three-part harmony thing. So, a beach boy meets Ramones type thing we were going for, I guess. But, um, um, um, the speed of the Ramones and the harmony of the beach boys, that was, I think,
有Mute Records的Daniel Miller签下了我们。不过他并没有真正签下我们。那只是一个握手。我们实际上从未签署过合同。真的吗？不。这就是那首歌《The Handshake》的由来吗？不，那可能只是……那是Martin，我写了那首歌，他当时可能只是对每个人都很生气。好吧。音乐，音乐产业，被一次又一次地欺骗。所以这个来自Mute Records的家伙，他在酒吧看到你们，
had Daniel Miller from mute records who signed us. He didn't really sign us, though. It was just a handshake. We never actually signed the contract. Really? No. Is that where the song, the handshake, there's a contract? No, it was probably just, that was a mark, in my own road that song, and he was probably just, that was a mark, in my mind, I rode that song and he was probably just angry at everybody at that point. Okay. Music, music, business, and being ripped off again and again and again. So this guy from U Records, he sees you wet in a pub,
你们在俱乐部演出，那是什么？是的，在酒吧。我们在一家叫The Bridge House的酒吧为他的另一个艺人Fat Gadget做暖场。Fat Gadget。你们得去听听Fat Gadget。你们会喜欢Fat Gadget的，很棒的音乐。真的吗？是的。你们得去听听Fat Gadget。你们会喜欢Fat Gadget的。很棒的音乐。
you're playing clubs, what was it? Yes, in a pub. We supported one of his other acts called Fat Gadget, at a pub called The Bridge House. Fat Gadget. You got to check out Fat Gadget. You guys are going to like Fat Gadget, great music. Really? Yes. You got to check out Faggy. You guys are going to like Faggy. Great music.
真的吗？是的。我真的要把它写下来。F-A-D-G-A-D-E-T。D-H-A-D-G-E-T。是的，我要把它写下来。你要把它写下来。没错。
Really? Yes. I'm actually going to write it down. F-A-D-G-A-D-E-T. D-H-A-D-G-E-T. Yeah, I'm going to write it down. You're going to write it down. That's right.
Martin上过学。我没有。哦。好吧，那你……我的意思是，Jason，有什么吗？没有。好吧。所以Daniel……Sohrer是Fat Gadget，当时我们的合成器设置好了，到那时我们已经全部换成合成器了。
Martin went to school. I did not. Oh. Well, then you're going to, I mean, Jason, anything? Nothing. Okay. So Daniel Sohrer is Fad Gadget with our synth set up on by that time we'd gone to all synths.
我们刚开始时乐队里有贝斯和吉他，但我们已经全部换成合成器了，我们把它们放在啤酒箱上。Daniel，Daniel印象深刻。是的。我们演奏得非常快。故事是这样的，他在伦敦东区Canningtown的一家小酒吧里为Fat Gadget混音，那家酒吧叫The Bridge House。我们周四晚上在那里驻场，那家伙，即使那里没人，
We started off with a bass and a guitar in the band, but we'd gone to all synths and we had them set up on our beer crates. And Daniel, Daniel was impressed. Yeah. We played really fast. And his story goes, he was mixing a sound for fact, just a little pub in the east end of London called the Bridge House in Canningtown. And we had a residency there on Thursday nights, the guy, even though nobody would be there,
大部分时间也就两个人加一条狗。作为Depeche Mode。是的。作为Depeche Mode。你知道，经营酒吧的那个人，他很看好我们，让我们周四晚上在那里演出。总之，我们得到了这次暖场机会，这很重要，因为我们喜欢Fat Gadget。而且你知道，Jason喜欢它。是的，你得去听听Fat Gadget。所以你们，
be like two people in a dog, most of the time. As the passionate. Yeah. As the passionate. And you know, a guy that ran the pub, he took a shine to us and sort of let us play there Thursday nights. Anyway, so we got this support, which was a big thing because we loved Fad Gadget. And you know, Jason loved it. Yeah, you've got to check out Fad Gaget. So you
你们去为这些人暖场，然后这个来自Mute Records的家伙说：“是的，你们为Fat Gadget暖场，还不错。”我们其实之前见过他，Vince和我跑遍了所有的唱片公司，我们去了伦敦的Rough Trade Records，以为我们做出了一个大师级的样带，他们会立刻签下我们，因为我们实际上有旋律，而他们当时的其他乐队都没有。那只是噪音。我们以为他们会立刻签下我们。经营那家唱片公司的家伙Scott，他其实并不感兴趣，但他听了我们的磁带。当他听磁带的时候，Daniel Miller碰巧走进了
guys, so you go and you support these guys and then this dude from from you records. Like, yeah, you guys are supporting Fad Gaget are pretty good. We actually met him before, Vince and I had trailed around all the record companies and we had gone to rough trade records in London thinking that we had made this masterful demo that they were going to sign us immediately because we actually had melody and most of their other bands at that time did not. There was just noise. And we thought they could have signed us immediately. And the guy that ran the record company Scott, he was not really interested, but he listened to our tape. And while he was listening to the tape, Daniel Miller happened to walk into
办公室，因为Fat Gadget当时是由Rough Trade发行的。他当时在为某件事大喊大叫，说他去了一家唱片店，里面没有唱片之类的。所以Scott大喊：“Daniel，你应该听听这个，也许你会……这是你可能感兴趣的东西。”他咕哝了一声，看了看我，然后坐在那里，只是……然后走开了，我们当时想：“去他的。”那是Mute Records的Daniel Miller。所以我们走出来，我想，这是机会，下一次机会，在为Fat Gadget开场时，Daniel在混音，他后来回来并实际上开始和我交谈，
the office because Fad Gadget was being distributed by rough trade at the time. And he was shouting about something that he'd gone in a record store and there was no records in there or something. So Scott shouted out, you know, Daniel, you should listen to this, maybe you'll be, this is something you might be interested in, he kind of growled a bit, looked over at me and then sitting there and just, you know, and walked out and we were like, well, fuck him. That's Daniel Miller from You Wreckly Knows. So we walked out there and this was, I guess, so the chance, the next chance, me, in when we were opening for Fab Gadget, Daniel was mixing the sound and he came back afterwards and started talking to me actually
因为他以为是我写的歌，因为是我唱的。我说，他问了我一些问题，然后他说：“是你写的歌吗？”我说：“不，那边那个家伙写的。”那就是Vince。所以他当然离开了，去和Vince谈了。在那之后，不，他说：“我能再来吗？”我想我们说我们下周四还要演出。他来了，他回来了，他问我们是否想做一张45转唱片。
because he thought I'd written the songs because I was singing them. And I said and he asked me some questions and then he said you write the songs. I was like no that bloke over there does and that was Vince. So he left me of course and went over and talked to Vince. And after that, no, he said, can I come back? And I think we said we were playing next Thursday. He did, and he came back, and he asked if we wanted to make a 45.
哇。一张单曲，也就是，是的。那是1981年左右。对吗，Martin？那大致正确吗？那是正确的，是的。确定吗？那是45转。
Wow. A single, which is, yeah. That's like 1981. Is that correct, Mark? Is that kind of correct? That is correct, yeah. Is that sure? It was a 45.
那时是45转。我们叫它单曲。那时是45转。我们叫它们单曲。那是47英寸的单曲，45转。他说：“我有足够的钱做那个。我……我们不需要签任何合同之类的。”但那大概是1980、81年。那是1980年。Daniel直到今天还和我们在一起。
It was a 45 then. We called him a single. It was a 45 then. We called them a single. It was a 47 inch single of 45. And he said, I've got enough money to do that. I will, we don't have to sign any contracts or anything. But so that's like 1980, 81. That was 1980. And Daniel was still involved with us today.
不，哇。是的。首先，这太不可思议了，而且你们有那种长久的关系。所以是1980年，你们写了这张唱片？你们在1980年写它的时候在听什么？是的，我也想说同样的话。你们在听什么，而且，你们当时想过，
No, wow. Yes. First of all, that's incredible and that's a, that you have that kind of long lasting relationship. So it's 1980 and what were you, you guys write this record? What were you listening to at the time that you wrote that in 1980? Yeah, I was going to say the same thing. What were you listening to and also were also, did you think back then,
你们是在追随潮流吗？音乐产业正在进入合成器流行乐，也许我们应该那样做？还是那真的是一种真诚的爱？它还没真正开始，对吧？我们是Mute Records的粉丝。是的，是的。所以，你知道，Daniel提供给我们
you were following a trend like where this, the music business is going into Synth Pop and maybe we should do that? Or was that truly a genuine love? It hadn't really started yet, had it? We were fans of mute records. Yeah, yeah. So, you know, the fact that Daniel was offering us
一个单曲合约，这对我们来说太棒了。是的。是的。是的。所以，你知道，Daniel提供给我们一个单曲合约，这对我们来说太棒了。是的。但当时在你们的磁带里有哪些乐队？嗯，像Fat Gadget，像，我的意思是，Daniel也有一段时间，有Deutsch-Amerikanische Freundschaft，也去听听他们。是的。是的。是的。他们用德语唱歌，The Normal。是的，The Normal就是Daniel本人。《Warm Leatherette》。你一定知道那个。
a one-off single deal, that was amazing to us. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, the fact that Daniel was offering us a one-off single deal, that was amazing to us. Yeah. But who are the bands that were at that time that were on you, you were playing on your tape cassettes? Well, like Fad Gadget, like, I mean, Daniel also, for a while, had a death, Deutsche-American, a Schaf Freund, checked them out as well. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They sing in German, the normal. Yeah, the normal was Daniel himself. Warm leatherette. You must know that.
你一定是从Grace Jones让它出名开始的，我想。我不知道我是否应该翻唱它。我今天下午，今天早上还在听Trio。你还记得那个吗？他们用小卡西欧琴做的。我刚才在听那个。我在听一些Blomange，我在听……Blomange，是的。Blomange和我们一起演出很多。
You must start out on Grace Jones made it famous, I guess. I don't know if I should cover it. I was just listening to this afternoon, this morning, I was just listening to Trio. Do you remember that? That they made up a little Casio. I was just listening to that. I was listening to some Blomage and I was listening to... From launch, yeah. From launch played with us a lot.
事实上，当时有一张专辑叫《Some Bizzare Album》。是由一个把它们放在一起的家伙做的。他的名字叫Stevo。他把它们放在一起，实际上，我们发行的第一张录音就在那张唱片上。那是一首叫《Photographic》的歌，它也在《Speak & Spell》里。但我们做了那张专辑的一部分。在那张专辑上，有来自早期曲目的任何人，
In fact, there was an album at the time called Some Bazaar album. It was by this guy who put it together. His name was Steve O. And he put together, actually, our first recording that came out was on that record. It was a song called Photographic, which was on Speak and Spell, too. But we did part of that album. And on that album, there was anyone from an early track
来自Soft Cell，来自Blomange，来自我们。是谁，Martin？那个……那个……哦，伙计。所以那是一张叫《Some Bizzare Album》的合辑。所以在那之后，很多那些艺人都签约了。嗯，那，你们，你们在音乐上对我来说就在那个最前沿。
from Soft Cell, from Blomange, from Us. Who was it, Mark? The, the. The, the, the. Oh, man. So it was a compilation called Sambazar album. So a lot of those acts after that got signed. Well, that was, you guys, you guys kind of were right at the forefront of that to me musically.
那个，你知道，听《Speak & Spell》首先，伟大的乐队，首先，你知道，这首歌《This Is the Day》仍然是一首赞歌。它让我想起我12岁时第一次剪酷发型。然后，然后，但听那个，你知道，听你们，听，然后Vince，当然，后来在英国组建了Yazoo，在美国也叫Yazoo，和Alison Moyet一起，然后他离开了，和Andy Bell组建了Erasure。但是虽然你们就在这一切的最前沿，我一直想知道，嗯，这些是很多人不知道的乐队，但你们并没有
The, the, you know, listening to the special first, great band that first, you know, this is the day is still just such an anthem. It reminds me of getting my first cool haircut when I was 12. And then, and then, but listen to that, you know, listen to you guys, listen to, and then Vince, of course, went on to form in the UK known as Yazoo, an American known as Yazoo with Allison Royay, and then he went off with Andy Bell and formed Rezor as well. And but though you guys were right there at the forefront of all of that, and I always wondered like, well, these are bands that not a lot of people know, but you guys weren't
听……那是后朋克。你记得，在英国。它正从……的灰烬中走出来。它结束了，朋克结束了，我们听The Clash，虽然……那是你们的？嗯，有The Pistols，The Clash，The Damned，Siouxsie and the Banshees，所有这些乐队都在某种程度上演变，
listening to... It was post punk. You go, remember, in are bands that not a lot of people know, but you guys weren't listening to It was post punk you go remember in England. It was coming out of the ashes of We it was over punk was over and we listen to clash though like was that your? Well, there was the pistols the clash the damned Susie and the band all these bands were kind of Evry vulvin Towards the end of like 77 78 into whatever that was coming or they
走向77、78年年底，无论那是什么，或者他们……在某种程度上，它结束了，你知道。我们那种“自己动手”的态度。是的，我想这就是我们建立的。嗯，你们，你们在那个过程中有了自己独特的声音，就像在朋克世界里，Paul Weller和The Jam从来没有真正完全融入朋克。对。而Paul，然后他最终，当然，你们可能认识他，他很棒，然后去做了Style Council。但以同样的方式，你们从不同的时代汲取灵感，或者诞生于不同的时代，然后创造了你们自己的
were kind of, it was over, you know. And we kind of, that do it yourself attitude. Yeah. I think is what we built into. Well, you guys were, you guys had your own unique sound coming out of that in the same way sort of in the punk world that like Paul Weller and the jam never really fit quite into the punk. Right. And Paul, and then he ended up of course, and you guys probably know him and he's amazing and went off and did style counsel. But in that same way that you guys kind of took from or were born out of a different era and then created your own
流派，我的意思是，不是要把你们放在聚光灯下，但因为当时没有多少人在做你们在做的事情，人们才开始做，我不喜欢，Bronsky Beat，你知道，他们在做东西，但他们是在你们之后，像《Speak & Spell》两年后。是的，这几乎就像我们有Bono在上面，我们在谈论，你知道，
genre in a way, I mean, not to put you in the spot, but because there weren't a lot of people who were making what you guys were doing, people just started doing, and I don't like, Bronsky beat, you know, they were doing stuff, but they came after you guys, like two years after speaking stuff. Yeah, it's almost like we had Bono on it, and we were talking about how, you know,
当所有这些流行歌星像Madonna，Michael Jackson，所有这些其他大的流行歌星。然后《The Joshua Tree》来了，这张专辑是如此……等等，什么？它是如此另类。然后你们来了，我想，以同样的方式，它就像，它偏离了其他人正在听的东西。那是，在1980年。我们并没有真正融入任何那些东西。
when all these pop start like Madonna, Michael Jackson, all these other kind of like big popsters. And here comes Joshua Tree, this album that was so like, wait, what? It's so alternative. And then you guys came along, I think, in the same kind of way, where it's just like, it was left of center from what everybody else is listening to. That's then, in like, 1980. We didn't really fit in any of that stuff.
是的，就是那种感觉。我们总是那种格格不入的乐队。有一波东西来了，但我们从来没有完全融入。我认为那是一件非常好的事情。我认为这很大程度上与Daniel Miller和他的指导有关，他允许我们慢慢地发展成我们想要成为的样子，到我们做《Black Celebration》的时候，我想我们已经找到了一点，在那之前，
Yeah, that's what it was like. We always kind of were the odd one band out in that. There was a wave of stuff that came, but we never quite fit. And I think that was a really good thing. And I think a lot of that was to do with Daniel Miller and his guidance in kind of allowing us to slowly like develop into what it was we wanted to be and by the time we got to black celebration I think we had kind of found a bit before
但我们找到了我们自己的……对吧，Martin？我们算是找到了……是的，花了我们所有……花了我们一段时间，是的。是的。我们马上回来。《SmartLess》由BetterHelp赞助。我想每周，如果我看看我花在自己身上的时间与花在别人身上的时间相比，我不知道我是否做得很好。我不知道我是否在照顾自己方面做得很好，我不认为我是唯一一个这样的人。我认为那是我们可以轻易地……从我们身边溜走的东西。很容易陷入每个人都需要你做什么，而不花点时间去想你需要什么。有时那只是
that but we had found our own why right Mark we sort of found yeah took us all we took us a while, yeah. Yeah. And we will be right back. SmartLess is sponsored by BetterHelp. I think every week to week, if I were to look at how much time I spend in myself versus how much time I spend on other people, I don't know if I do a very good job. I don't know if I do a good job with taking care of myself and I don't think I'm alone in that. I think that that's something that we can easily kind of get away from us. It's it's it's easy to get caught up in what everyone else needs from you and not take a moment to think about what you need from yourself. And sometimes that's
一种安静的时刻。有时那是某种反思，审视我在事情中的角色，并试图理解这种动态。或者审视我为了自己的心理健康需要什么才能感觉更好。我并不是唯一一个有这种想法的人，当我们把所有时间都花在给予上，并感到我们正在付出大量能量，情感上和其他方面，这会让我们感到非常紧张、疲惫和精疲力竭。我发现治疗可以给你工具，在你的生活中找到更多的平衡，这样你就可以继续支持他人，而不会把自己抛在后面。多年来，我从治疗中受益匪浅，它给了我一种我无法独自获得的视角，我需要通过谈论
just sort of a quiet moment. Sometimes that's some reflection and looking at my role in things and trying to understand the dynamic. Or looking at what I need for my own mental health to feel better. I'm not alone in this idea that when we spend all of our time giving and feeling that we're putting out a lot of energy, emotional and otherwise, it can leave us feeling pretty stretched, thin and pretty burned out. I have found that therapy can give you the tools to find more balance in your life so that you can keep supporting others without leaving yourself behind. I've really benefited from therapy over the years and it's given me the perspective that I can't always get on my own and that I need to get from a therapist through talking about
我的经历从治疗师那里获得。如果你正在考虑开始治疗，给BetterHelp一个机会。它完全在线，旨在方便、灵活，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并可随时免费更换治疗师。用BetterHelp找到更多的平衡。今天访问betterhelp.com/smartless，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp.com/smartless。
my experience. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give Better Help a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. Find more balance with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today and get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash smartless.
《SmartLess》得到了Vuori服装的支持。你厌倦了为了舒适而牺牲风格，或者反之亦然吗？看看Vuori吧。Vuori是结合了风格和舒适的性能服装品牌。你知道，你知道这个。我之前告诉过你很多关于Vuori的事情，他们有慢跑裤、紧身裤到圆领衫，他们有你需要的一切来保持舒适和……你知道，你知道这个，我之前告诉过你很多关于Vuori的事情，他们有慢跑裤、紧身裤到圆领衫，他们有你需要的一切来保持舒适和时尚，但嗯，你之前已经听我说过所有这些了。
Smartless gets support from Viori clothing. Are you tired of sacrificing style for comfort or vice versa? Look no further than Viori. Viori is the performance clothing brand that combines both style and comfort. You know what, you know this. I've told you a lot about Viori before that they got joggers to leggings to crew next and they have everything you need to stay comfy and comfort. And you know what, you know this, I've told you a lot about viewer before, they got joggers to leggings to crew next, and they have everything you need to stay comfy and stylish, but well, you've heard me say all that before.
好吧，现在，记住这一点，不要扔掉它，但我现在要告诉你一些事情。在我谈论Vuori的所有时间里，它有多棒，你可以穿着它去健身房，然后你可以穿着它去办公室，你可以穿着它去洗车，你可以穿着它去看牙医。你可以穿着它去洗车，你可以穿着它去看牙医。你也可以在做播客时穿着它。
Okay, now, keep that in mind, don't throw it away, but I'm gonna tell you something right now. Of all the time that I've talked about viewering, how great it is, you can wear it to the gym, and then you can wear it to the office, and you can wear it to the car wash, and you can wear it to the dentist. You can wear it to the car wash and you can wear it to the dentist. You can also wear it while you're making a podcast.
所以是的，当你现在听我说话时，我正穿着我的Core短裤坐在这里，好吗？Vuori的Core衬衫是如此……这就像一个，我希望我可以穿着它去参加高级晚宴，我希望我可以穿着它去参加婚礼……我希望我可以穿着它去参加婚礼。我只是永远不想脱掉我的Core短裤。这听起来像某种住在加利福尼亚的高傲演员。
So yeah, as you're listening to me right now, I'm sitting here in my core shorts, okay? The core shirt from Vury is so, this is like a, I wish I could wear it to like a fancy dinner, I wish I could wear it to like a wedding.. I wish I could wear it to like a wedding. I just never want to take my core shorts off and short. This sounds like some sort of high flute and actor who lives in California.
猜猜怎么着，你不需要是。你可以只是你自己，你可以穿着Core短裤去任何地方。这就是重点，对于我们的听众，他们提供首次购买20%的折扣。在Vuori.com/smartless上为自己购买地球上最舒适、最通用的服装。那是V-U-O-R-I点com斜杠smartless。你不仅会收到首次购买20%的折扣，你还将享受免费送货
Guess what, you don't need to be. You can just be you and you can wear the core short anywhere. And here's the thing, for our listener, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viewerry.com slash smartless. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping
任何超过75美元的美国订单，以及免费退货。只需前往vuori.com/smartless，探索Vuori服装的多功能性。[♪ 背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，嘿SmartLess听众，Amazon 5 Star Reviews呈现“比BO更好用”。我们的第一个客户评论来自Rico写道，
on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Just go to viewory.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of view-or-e clothing. [♪ music playing in background, playing in background, Hey smartless listener, Amazon 5 Star Reviews presents works better than BO. Our first customer review is from Rico writes,
所有美国境内超过75美元的订单均可享受免运费和免费退货服务。只需访问viewory.com/smartless，即可探索Viewory服装的多样性。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，嘿，Smartless的听众们，Amazon 5星好评为您呈现“效果胜过BO”。我们的第一条客户评论来自Rico，他写道，
I purchased this crafting with cat hair book on Amazon, as I was tired of people sitting to near me on public transportation. The book worked like a charm, five stars. Rico, my friend, that is some next level problem solving. And that's how to make everyday better five stars. Now let's hear about Jennifer's miniature miracles of life. She writes,
我在亚马逊上买了这本《用猫毛做手工》的书，因为我厌倦了在公共交通工具上有人坐在我旁边。这本书效果出奇地好，五星好评。Rico，我的朋友，那可是更高层面的问题解决方式。这就是让每一天变得更好的方法，五星好评。现在让我们来听听Jennifer的微型生命奇迹。她写道：
bought 200 mini-plastic babies on Amazon to hide for my fiance to find. He thought I had one or two, he thought wrong. Hearing him find baby number 175, brought me more joy than I could ever describe. I give trolling your spouse with miniature miracles of life, five stars. Way to put anybody baby shaped plastic to good use, Jennifer, that's how you make every day better.
我在亚马逊上买了200个迷你塑料婴儿，藏起来让我未婚夫找。他以为我只有一两个，他想错了。听着他找到第175个婴儿时，我感到的快乐无法用言语形容。我给这种用微型生命奇迹来捉弄配偶的行为打五星。Jennifer，你真会利用这些婴儿形状的塑料制品，这就是你让每一天变得更好的方式。
Another five stars. Realize my customers, real reviews, really. And now back to the show. Martin so Vince Lee, as I alluded to, Vince leaves and goes and goes and does first does Yazoo. And Martin did you, so then you started writing more because because Vincent was, were you guys equally writing, or how did that happen that you sort of stepped into that position? Well, I don't even mean to put it, I don't know how to, I wrote a couple of songs on the first album.
又是一个五星好评。真实的客户，真实的评论，真的。现在回到节目。Martin，那么Vince呢，正如我提到的，Vince离开了，去做了Yazoo。Martin，那你呢，你是从那时开始写更多歌的吗？是因为Vincent离开了，你们当时是平分写歌任务，还是怎么发生的，让你进入了那个位置？嗯，我甚至不想这么说，我不知道该怎么说，我在第一张专辑里写了几首歌。
And, yeah, because I was the only one who actually wrote songs when this left I kind of had to do it. Right. It was just like, we were like like, so and Daniel Literally was like, is anybody else write songs? Because you're right or is left? And we were like, is that me? It's over. And it's sort of, mine was like, I'll go a couple of songs. See, look.
是的，因为当Vince离开时，我是唯一一个真正写歌的人，所以我不得不这么做。对。当时就像，我们就像，Daniel真的问，还有人写歌吗？因为你写还是他写？我们当时就想，是我吗？结束了。然后，我就说，我会写几首歌。你看，瞧。
Well, yeah, I was lucky, but you know, well, the album was a very weird collection of songs, because some of them I wrote when I was 16, and then some of them I was making up in the studio when we were trying to finish the album. Which album, Black Celebration, you mean? A Broken Frame. No, Broken Frame, sorry.
嗯，是的，我很幸运，但你知道，那张专辑是一张非常奇怪的歌曲合集，因为有些歌是我16岁时写的，而有些是我在录音室试图完成专辑时临时创作的。哪张专辑，《Black Celebration》吗？《A Broken Frame》。不，是《Broken Frame》，抱歉。
A Broken Frame. Okay, so what was the... After he left and you stepped into that role, as Dave says, because everybody else was looking around, going, who the fuck's gonna do this? What was the first... When you started writing, what was the first sort of big hit that you wrote,
《A Broken Frame》。好吧，那么……在他离开你接手那个角色后，正如Dave所说，因为其他人都在环顾四周，想着，到底谁来干这个？什么是第一首……当你开始写歌时，你写的第一首大热单曲是什么？
and everybody's like, Ah, fuck yeah, Martin, well done, man. Like, it was straight away at first. The first thing we recorded was, see you. And then you released that as a single, and that was a massive hit, so. Wow. We actually went the highest.
然后大家都说，啊，太棒了，Martin，干得好，伙计。就像是立刻就成功了。我们录的第一首歌是《See You》。然后你们把它作为单曲发行了，那是一首巨大的热门歌曲，所以。哇。我们实际上达到了最高点。
We'd gone into charts. And then we went to number six was a big thing. And Martin had this new synthesizer, the P-P-G. And so we didn't use much equipment in the studio. It was like a few pieces, down your way to a couple of pieces of electronic stuff. And so you kind of were very,
我们进入了排行榜。然后我们到了第六名，那是一件大事。Martin当时有了一台新的合成器，PPG。所以我们在录音室里没用太多设备。就像几件东西，Daniel那边也就几件电子设备。所以你当时非常……
and it was no sampling then. There was no, you know, it wasn't like, well, how, how, now you you kind of were very and it was no good song. It was a great pop song. It was like sort of, Evily Bravo's song or something. We, you know, went on TV and it was a big hit. I think it was more Herman's Hermits. Ha ha ha. Mrs. Brown, you've got a lovely...
那时还没有采样。没有，你知道，不像现在，你当时非常……那是一首好歌。那是一首很棒的流行歌曲。就像是某种Evelyn Bravo的歌之类的。我们，你知道，上了电视，那是一首大热单曲。我觉得更像是Herman's Hermits的风格。哈哈，Mrs. Brown，你有一个可爱的……
I was going to say to me, I was, but I thought that was too soft. It was the bright, we were young. My grandparents used to have a Herman's Herman's record for some reason, and we used to play it when we were kids. Do you remember that Mrs. Brown? You've got a lovely boy. Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah.
我本来想说对我来说，我，但我以为那太柔和了。那是明亮的，我们当时很年轻。我祖父母不知为何有一张Herman's Hermits的唱片，我们小时候常放。你记得那首《Mrs. Brown, You've Got a Lovely Daughter》吗？是的，是的，是的。
You go remember, I was only 10 when this was happening. Yeah, yeah. Are you guys so shocked that your song just can't get enough is used everywhere always? It could be anything. It's a tampon ad, It's like in a cocaine bear. It's like, you know, it's, it is. It fits, it fits everywhere.
你得记住，这发生时我才10岁。是的，是的。你们对自己的歌《Just Can't Get Enough》到处被使用感到震惊吗？它什么都能用。它是卫生棉广告，它出现在《Cocaine Bear》里。它就是，你知道，它就是。它很合适，它到处都合适。
It's, yeah. I mean, if all your songs, I really do know, probably every word to every song. And I'm like, that's the song everybody plays everywhere. I'm like, wait, it's, you know, it's funny. When, when Vince wrote that song, I think we were the first publisher that he had. We were at the offices, and I think Rod Buckle remember,
是的。我是说，如果你所有的歌，我真的知道，可能每一首歌的每一个字。我心想，那是每个人到处都在放的歌。我心想，等等，你知道，这很有趣。当Vince写那首歌时，我想我们是他拥有的第一家出版商。我们在办公室里，我想Rod Buckle记得，
I seem to remember him saying, like he said something like this to the rest of us, we were sitting on the couch, we were kind of squashed together, and he looked at Vince and he said, you know, he said, he is going to be driving a Rolls-Royce, while you three are on the tandem. And we were like, you know, he said he is going to be driving a Rolls Royce while you three are on the tandem.
我似乎记得他说过，就像他对我们其他人说的那样，我们当时坐在沙发上，挤在一起，他看着Vince说，你知道，他说，他以后会开着劳斯莱斯，而你们三个会骑着双人自行车。我们当时就想，你知道，他说他以后会开着劳斯莱斯，而你们三个会骑着双人自行车。
And we were like, you know, I think I see call, you know, like we were like, what, why? Like it was, and we all signed this deal. I think he gave us a hundred quid each for like to sign a publisher, not waiting it to, to, he did. And then we really, we were like, he's giving us a hundred quid for nothing. Signed, we can buy a tandem for that. Yeah, we will buy that tandem. But Vince... You know, he told Vince, you know, you'll be driving in a Rolls Royce.
我们当时就想，你知道，我想我明白了，你知道，我们当时想，什么，为什么？就像是，我们都签了这份协议。我想他给了我们每人一百英镑来签出版合同，不用等……他给了。然后我们真的，我们当时想，他给了我们一百英镑，什么都没做。签了，我们可以买辆双人自行车。是的，我们会买那辆双人自行车。但Vince……你知道，他告诉Vince，你知道，你会开着劳斯莱斯。
And he said, this song is going to continue, like, forever. It's going to be different. And we were just kind of like, don't think so. Yeah, you know what I'm saying? But, yeah. But we were very impressed because he took us out for lunch
他说，这首歌会一直流传下去，永远。它会与众不同。我们当时只是觉得，不太可能吧。是的，你知道我在说什么吗？但是，是的。但我们印象非常深刻，因为他带我们去吃午饭，
and Errol Brown from Hot Chocolate was in the same restaurant. Yes. That's all right. Remember that. Do you remember the band Hot Chocolate? No! You guys are two even locals. Oh, yeah.. Oh yeah.
Hot Chocolate乐队的Errol Brown也在同一家餐厅。是的。没关系。记得那个。你记得Hot Chocolate乐队吗？不！你们两个太本地人了。哦，是的……哦，是的。
It's hot chocolate, I woke up. That's an interesting thing. We were like, oh shit. Is that all brown from hot chocolate? So you have some hits in the UK, obviously. What was your first recognition in the US that you knew that people were listening to the band in the US? Well, I think that just can't get enough,
是Hot Chocolate的《I'll Put You Together Again》。那是一件有趣的事。我们当时想，哦天哪。那是Hot Chocolate的Errol Brown吗？所以你们在英国显然有一些热门歌曲。你们在美洲第一次获得认可，让你们知道人们在听你们乐队，是什么时候？嗯，我想《Just Can't Get Enough》，
did get some underground play, like obviously club play and stuff like that. But I think the first radio thing was probably people are people. Yeah, it was huge. And it was still like a really underground. It was, we were never really played on mainstream radio. Right. And then talk about, first of all, just side of our, I used to get, I looked like exactly
确实在地下电台播放过，显然是在俱乐部播放之类的。但我认为第一首电台歌曲可能是《People Are People》。是的，它非常火。而且它仍然非常地下。它，我们从未真正在主流电台播放过。对。然后谈谈，首先，只是关于我们的，我过去看起来完全，
like Dave Gond, all the time in college. People were like, you look just like Dave Gond, and this is that picture. Yeah. Wow. Wow. You better look in though. You got better. You got better.
就像大学里的Dave Gahan。人们说，你看起来就像Dave Gahan，这就是那张照片。是的。哇。哇。你看起来更好。你变好了。你变好了。
No, no, no. The Rose Bowl wasn't that just life career changing when you sold out the Rose Bowl to everybody. That was later. It was a very happy accident, to be honest. It was. It was. But it blew everybody's mind. I remember the press was like, wait, what?
不，不，不。玫瑰碗体育场那次，当你们卖光了玫瑰碗的票时，那不是改变人生的一刻吗？那是后来。老实说，那是一个非常快乐的意外。确实是。确实是。但这让所有人都震惊了。我记得媒体当时说，等等，什么？
60,000. It blew our minds. I mean, we were not prepared, really. It was one of those things that I think it was as suggested to us that we could do this at the end of that particular tour of Music for the Masses tour. A big show somewhere where all the fans would travel like in a grateful dead way. We kind of had that kind of following.
6万张票。这让我们震惊。我是说，我们真的没有准备好。那是我们认为在《Music for the Masses》巡演结束时可以做的事情之一。在某个地方举办一场大型演出，所有的粉丝都会像追随Grateful Dead那样旅行。我们当时确实有那种追随者。
And they did. There was people in there, but we ended up doing it. And DA Penny Baker filmed the whole thing for us, which was also kind of iconic to be now looking back. I see pictures from then, I see Penny is not with us anymore, but we used to think he was extremely old. Like when we were on that tour and he was, you know, document in the whole thing with us, he was like this old guy. We used to sort of like help him around the stage, you know. But be careful with that 35-minute movie. You're going to fall overdid. Like, and he'd be kept, he was like, maybe 50?
他们确实来了。那里有人，但我们最终还是做了。D.A. Pennebaker为我们拍摄了整个过程，现在回想起来，这也是一种标志性的东西。我看到那时的照片，Penny现在已经不在我们身边了，但我们过去认为他非常老。就像我们在那次巡演时，他，你知道，记录了整个过程，他就像个老头。我们过去常在舞台上帮他，你知道。小心那个35毫米摄像机。你会摔倒的。就像，他当时，他可能50岁？
I don't know. Like, and we were like, so old. Like, this guy, who's this guy? And he was just amazed with what he was amazed with. Not really the music or anything. It was the scale. It was the scale. It was the fans. It was kind of at the front.
我不知道。就像，我们当时想，太老了。这个人，他是谁？他只是对所见感到惊讶。不是音乐或什么。是规模。是规模。是粉丝。它就在前面。
The fandom, yeah. It was the fandom. It was like the cult of the following that we had. Why are they obsessed with this band? And to still to this day, there is that sign. We carry that sign. It's like, the church of depression or something, you know. Yeah, yeah.
粉丝群体，是的。是粉丝群体。就像我们拥有的那种邪教般的追随者。为什么他们对这个乐队如此痴迷？直到今天，那个标志还在。我们带着那个标志。就像，抑郁教堂之类的，你知道。是的，是的。
Does that feel heavy sometimes, or is it something that changes your relationship to a does it kind of shift? No, I mean, one thing I've realized recently though, is that I'm a big soccer fan. And soccer fans always think, they know better I'm a big soccer fan. And, you know, soccer fans always think, you know, they know better than the manager of the team they support. Oh, yeah. We know that. So, so our fans, like, you've gone on any of the forums, you know,
这有时感觉沉重吗，还是说它改变了你与它的关系，它会发生转变吗？不，我是说，我最近意识到的一件事是，我是个足球迷。足球迷总是认为，他们比他们支持的球队经理更懂。哦，是的。我们知道。所以，我们的粉丝，就像，你去任何论坛，你知道，
all of our fans, you know, they're always complaining. They're never happy with what we do. They're, they're basically Arsenal supporters like. Wait, wait, Mark, are you an Arsenal supporter? I am. So you're from... Did you wrap it in North London then, or...? No, we East London. I should have been a wet...
我们所有的粉丝，你知道，他们总是在抱怨。他们对我们做的事情从不满意。他们基本上就是阿森纳的支持者。等等，等等，Martin，你是阿森纳的支持者吗？我是。所以你来自……那你是在北伦敦长大的吗，还是……？不，我们是东伦敦。我本应该是……
I thought you were going to be West Ham. Yeah, I should have been a West Ham supporter, but no. You know, you just... You make a decision when you're like nine or ten, don't you? Yeah. And you stick with it, you can't change. Where we came from was like Arsenal, West Ham, or Chelsea, don't you? And you stick with it, you can't change. Where we came from, it was like Arsenal, Westam or Chelsea, basically. Yeah, that was kind of like...
我以为你会是西汉姆联的。是的，我本应该是西汉姆联的支持者，但没有。你知道，你只是……你在九岁或十岁时做了一个决定，不是吗？是的。然后你坚持下去，你不能改变。我们来自的地方就像阿森纳、西汉姆联或切尔西，不是吗？你坚持下去，你不能改变。我们来自的地方，基本上就是阿森纳、西汉姆联或切尔西。是的，那就像是……
Dave, are you a football supporter? Do you have a... I was a Chelsea fan, so I really... And I stopped going into Chelsea after getting a total beating, actually, Arsenal, a way of Arsenal. I got chased down the street by a bunch of Arsenal fans, ended up rolling underneath a car to escape death. Where I just got such a beating. I think I was about 15, I was the last time I went to a half hour. I let them away by the way.
Dave，你是足球支持者吗？你有……我是切尔西球迷，所以我真的……我后来不再去切尔西了，因为我被彻底打了一顿，实际上，是阿森纳，阿森纳的客场。我被一群阿森纳球迷追着跑，最后滚到车底下才逃过一劫。我被打得太惨了。我想我当时大约15岁，那是我最后一次去客场。顺便说一句，我让他们走了。
I let them. You finally let them. I mean, mine's done that a few times for me. You're not a guy. There were, it was at first and then like this is too much. I just read this book by this writer Bill Buford called Among the Thugs, which is about, I don't know if you read that about. That was it. The Chelsea crew were called the Crazy Gang. And it was basically people went to soccer to fight. That was kind of what it was. It was, it was, it was these huge, and
我让他们走了。你终于让他们走了。我是说，Martin也为我做过几次。你不是那种人。有，起初是，然后就像这太过分了。我刚读了作家Bill Buford写的《Among the Thugs》，是关于，我不知道你读过没有。就是那个。切尔西的团伙叫“疯狂帮”。基本上人们去足球场就是为了打架。那就是当时的情况。就是，就是，这些巨大的，而且
it got scary. It got really, it got really to the point where it was very dangerous. It was a movie that Gary Oldham's in actually the firm. I've seen it. That's very much what it was about the West Ham supporters about those. It was Chelsea supporters and West Ham supporters, I think, Millwall to like Millwall. Oh, Millwall, that's tough. That's tough. Yeah, man.
它变得很可怕。它真的到了非常危险的地步。有一部Gary Oldman演的电影，实际上叫《The Firm》。我看过。那讲的就是西汉姆联的支持者，关于那些。那是切尔西支持者和西汉姆联支持者，我想，还有米尔沃尔，像米尔沃尔。哦，米尔沃尔，那很强硬。那很强硬。是的，伙计。
Hey, guys, where did the, I just remember always being so taken by the mood you guys set with your music and also your stage craft The whole aesthetic of the band it was it is so Sort of I don't know what the right term would be dramatic cinematic Yeah, but I mean I don't I don't remember that Anybody blazing a trail before you guys in that world is many many sort of People that try to replicate that since then, for sure. But where did that comfort, was that deliberate, or was it just kind of where you guys were at?
嘿，伙计们，那个，我只是记得一直被你们音乐营造的氛围所吸引，还有你们的舞台艺术。整个乐队的美学，它非常，我不知道正确的词是什么，戏剧性的，电影般的。是的，但我是说，我不记得在你们之前有人在那个领域开辟过道路。从那以后肯定有很多模仿者。但那种舒适感从何而来，是故意的，还是只是你们当时的状态？
Were you inspired by something? I think we were lucky when we wrote Black Celebration that we got involved with Anton Kulbin, who became the kind of like the visual head for the band. Who's that? I'm an idiot. He's an incredible writer. There were a lot of videos, yeah. Yeah. But he's a film writer. He's a very tall Dutchman. He's a very tall Dutchman. He started out as a photographer. Okay. But you know, you make for the NME, for the NME, we did a new musical express in London. It was, he got to be the front cover guy, that would do the covers of that paper.
你们受到什么启发了吗？我想我们在写《Black Celebration》时很幸运，我们接触到了Anton Corbijn，他成为了乐队的视觉负责人。那是谁？我是个白痴。他是一位了不起的导演。有很多视频，是的。是的。但他是一位电影导演。他是一个非常高的荷兰人。他是一个非常高的荷兰人。他最初是一名摄影师。好吧。但你知道，你为《NME》做的，为伦敦的《New Musical Express》。他成了封面人物，会做那份报纸的封面。
And it would always be like this amazing photograph of Joy Division or Echo and the Bunny Man or Suzy Su from the band. She's always were Anton Shots. So the chances of us, kind of at that time, working with Anton were pretty slim, but we got, the first time time working with Anton, we're pretty slim, but we got the first time we worked with him, I think, was AE1, actually, and then we didn't work with him again till
那总是Joy Division或Echo and the Bunnymen或Siouxsie Sioux的精彩照片。她总是Anton拍的。所以我们当时和Anton合作的机会相当渺茫，但我们得到了，我们第一次和他合作，我想，实际上是《A Question of Time》，然后直到……
what AE5, Mar, AE6, with Black Celebration. We got the cover of the NME, Anton was shooting it, and he had to shoot it. He had to shoot it. He had to shoot it. He had to. He had to shoot it. I don't think he really wanted to, because he was very cool. And we weren't. And, you know, I mean, we were trying to be cool, but. And did he style that shoot in such a way
什么《A Question of Time》，Martin，《A Question of Lust》，《Black Celebration》。我们上了《NME》的封面，Anton在拍，他不得不拍。他不得不拍。他不得不拍。他不得不拍。我不认为他真的想拍，因为他很酷。而我们不是。而且，你知道，我是说，我们试图变酷，但是。他是否以某种方式设计了那次拍摄，
that you guys sort of borrowed from and adopted going forward? I think it sort of began there, even though we weren't probably aware of it. But by the time we, like mine said, even though we weren't probably aware of it, but by the time we, like I might have said, by the time we got to Black Celebration, we had been working in Berlin, Hansa Studios, the very famous iconic answer for it, Bowie had recorded and Iggy and various other people that we looked up to and were influenced by.
让你们借用并采纳了？我想它从那里开始了，尽管我们可能没有意识到。但当我们，就像Martin说的，尽管我们可能没有意识到，但当我们到了《Black Celebration》时，我们一直在柏林的Hansa Studios工作，那个非常著名、标志性的Hansa，Bowie录过音，Iggy和我们仰慕并受其影响的各种其他人也录过音。
And, you know, I think that's where it really started for us. Martin had moved to Berlin as well for a short period of time there as well. And we started working there a lot. West Berlin. This was West Berlin as well. When the wall was very much, of course, still up. And we used to work right, there was a studio called Hansard. It was right on the wall.
而且，你知道，我想那就是我们真正开始的地方。Martin也曾在柏林住过一段时间。我们开始在那里大量工作。西柏林。这也是西柏林。当时墙当然还在。我们过去常在墙边工作，有一个叫Hansa的录音室。它就在墙边。
So when you were on the balcony of the studio You literally were looking over the wall and you'd see these soldiers, you know, so Hence the bowies line in heroes, but about the you know the wall, I think Heroes always reminds me of Christian Af. Remember that film's in West Berlin? That's right. Wait, it was on the soundtrack. Yeah, yeah. That's a great film. Do you guys also, I'm sorry for the dumb dumb question and you guys have probably answered this a billion times,
所以当你在录音室的阳台上时，你真的可以看到墙那边，你会看到那些士兵，你知道，所以，因此Bowie在《Heroes》里的歌词，关于，你知道，那堵墙，我想《Heroes》总是让我想起《Christiane F.》。记得那部在西柏林拍的电影吗？没错。对了。它在原声带里。是的，是的。那是一部伟大的电影。你们也，抱歉问个愚蠢的问题，你们可能已经回答过十亿次了，
but I don't know. Is there why the religious undertones, so many of them? I don't know, they just spirituality, bro. They both just turned sweating. I know. I've never been religious. Yeah. No, I'm always searching. You know, I mean, I'm not just a spirituality, Brian. I mean, I've never been religious. I'm always searching. You know, I'm always searching.
但我不知道。为什么有宗教色彩，这么多？我不知道，只是灵性，兄弟。他们两个都开始出汗了。我知道。我从来没有宗教信仰。是的。不，我一直在寻找。你知道，我是说，我不仅仅是灵性，兄弟。我是说，我从来没有宗教信仰。我一直在寻找。你知道，我一直在寻找。
Yeah, sure. And then I feel often, especially when I'm singing my words, and there's this kind of also, sometimes it's like a... It can be like an experience that when you're singing and sometimes you're kind of in a big place like we just did the garden or whatever, and you're certain gigs that you do, it's this sort of experience, it is like a sort of, I don't know, spiritual experience. Yeah, something that's there and it's also, I have a kind of disdain for it too, it feels like, experience. Yeah, something that's there. And there's also I have a kind of disdain for it to it feels like, you know,
是的，当然。然后我经常感觉到，特别是在我唱我的歌词时，有一种，有时它就像一个……它可能是一种体验，当你唱歌时，有时你在一个很大的地方，就像我们刚在麦迪逊广场花园做的那样，或者其他什么，你做的某些演出，这是一种体验，它就像一种，我不知道，精神体验。是的，某种存在的东西，而且，我也有一种蔑视，它感觉就像，体验。是的，某种存在的东西。而且我也有一种蔑视，它感觉就像，你知道，
like a lot of bollocks as well. Yeah, it's the same time. I mean, you even sort of take it, I mean, I've always loved blasphemous rumors because I just love that lyric. I don't want to start any blasphemous rumors. But I think the gods got a six-year humor. And when I die, I expect to find him laughing. Laughing, yeah. I've always been obsessed to really... People miss the comedy, see? They miss the comedy in what we do.
就像很多废话一样。是的，同时。我是说，你甚至会，我是说，我一直很喜欢《Blasphemous Rumours》，因为我就是喜欢那句歌词。“我不想散布任何亵渎的谣言，但我认为上帝有种六岁的幽默感。当我死时，我期待发现他在笑。”在笑，是的。我一直很痴迷于真正……人们错过了喜剧，明白吗？他们错过了我们所做事情中的喜剧。
They just sort of miss the humor from Martin. And they miss the delivery from Dave. But it's all there. You just got a little bit of a... The only thing brought it up because I love the comment and the cleverness of the the language that you choose. It's really cool. But then it also did fit into Jason kind of what you were asking about into the the the sort of yeah. Yeah, it became. And you get that you get that I think we like that. I think we're comfortable in that imagery.
他们只是错过了Martin的幽默。他们错过了Dave的表达。但它都在那里。你只需要一点点……我提起它是因为我喜欢你们选择的语言的评论和聪明才智。真的很酷。但它也确实符合Jason你问的关于那种，是的。是的，它变成了。而且你得到那个，我想我们喜欢那个。我想我们在那种意象中很自在。
A bit of theater. And yeah, yeah. Well, what was it about the writing though, Dave, that always sort of kind of presented a block for you because obviously you're a very intelligent man, know how to speak, know how to write, I'm sure, and then tell stories and whatnot. But when it comes to lyrics, is it, and Martin, I'm sure you can speak better to this too, is there an attempt to tell a story when you write a lyric or just to set some poetry that then obviously the music comes later to fit that or vice versa?
一点戏剧性。是的，是的。好吧，Dave，写作中有什么总是让你感到阻碍，因为显然你是一个非常聪明的人，知道怎么说话，知道怎么写，我相信，还能讲故事之类的。但当涉及到歌词时，是，Martin，我相信你也能更好地谈论这一点，写歌词时是试图讲一个故事，还是只是设定一些诗意，然后音乐稍后跟进以适应它，反之亦然？
What was the thing that kept you away from it early on, Dave? Well, in the early days and also, you know, even now when we're singing a lot of these great songs at Mines Ren, they always change too. They change over the years depending on what's going on in your life. They represent something different and they have memories, songs and memories, you know, and they're there and they're there to also develop new memories and the viet to come, you know. But I feel like if you really tap into a good song when you're writing and there's something and it doesn't, you know, you kind of have to work it sometimes, but sometimes if you really let go of control of the lyric or whatever and allow something to just, you know,
Dave，早期是什么让你远离它？嗯，在早期，而且，你知道，即使是现在，当我们唱Martin写的许多这些伟大的歌时，它们总是会变。它们多年来一直在变，取决于你生活中发生的事情。它们代表了不同的东西，它们有记忆，歌曲和记忆，你知道，它们在那里，它们也为了发展新的记忆和未来，你知道。但我感觉如果你在写作时真正触及了一首好歌，并且有什么东西，它不需要，你知道，你有时必须努力，但有时如果你真正放开对歌词的控制，或者其他什么，允许某种东西只是，你知道，
it's a combination of things that might happen at the same time, you could just follow the idea, you know, it's just allow it to just, you know, and other things you have to, you have to kind of like, you know, move, when we work in a studio together, for instance, if Martin's, you know, is always right, and the majority of the songs, I try and create, I work with a song for a long time before I actually go to finally sing it. So I want to live with that song for a long time, and when I step up to the mic, I already know where I want to go with it, and it's always somewhere visual. It's a visual voice. But the melody that perhaps you've written to go with it or chosen to go with it, I would imagine would inform what words work or what words don't work more.
这是可能同时发生的事情的组合，你可以跟随这个想法，你知道，只是允许它，你知道，其他事情你必须，你必须有点像，你知道，移动，当我们一起在录音室工作时，例如，如果Martin的，你知道，总是对的，大部分歌曲，我尝试并创造，我在最终演唱之前会和一首歌工作很长时间。所以我想和那首歌生活很长时间，当我走到麦克风前时，我已经知道我想去哪里了，它总是视觉化的。这是一个视觉化的声音。但你可能为它写或选择的旋律，我想会影响哪些词有效，哪些词无效。
It can. They serve each other. And a lot of the time it's about removing stuff. We did that law on this record. We sort of, there's a lot of clutter that you automatically put in place because you think it's supposed to be there, but quite often it's removing things
可以。它们互相服务。很多时候是关于删除东西。我们在唱片上做了很多。我们有点，有很多杂乱的东西是你自动放进去的，因为你认为它应该在那里，但通常是删除东西
to allow a simple idea to really come through. All right, and I love like, you know, almost all your melodies that you guys write are you think it's gonna go to the obvious one that the ear is familiar with and boom, you take a lot of time. That's my, that's my, he'll take one of my songs for instance that we were working say a song like wagon tongue which is on this record and I sent my little demo to Martin of me like
以允许一个简单的想法真正显现出来。好吧，我喜欢，你知道，几乎你们写的所有旋律，你认为它会走向耳朵熟悉的那个明显的旋律，然后砰，你花了很多时间。那是我的，那是我的，他会拿走我的一首歌，例如我们正在做的像《Wagon Tongue》这样的歌，它在这张唱片上，我把我的小样发给Martin，我像
hand-fistedly playing on a guitar trying to get the song out and find the chords and and I send it to Martin and Martin sends it back with his beautiful, like, crop work, S-collect, the chords, and arpeggiating sense of stuff. And I'm like, oh, okay. Yeah. And that's up. But then that takes me then to another place, you see. Right, yeah. It changes the perception, yeah, again, I'm sure it's the same with you guys when you're
笨拙地在吉他上弹奏，试图把歌唱出来，找到和弦，然后我把它发给Martin，Martin把它发回来，带着他美丽的，像，作品，和弦，和琶音合成器之类的东西。我心想，哦，好吧。是的。而那把我带到了另一个地方，你看。对，是的。它改变了感知，是的，再次，我相信你们在
working in film and behind or in front of the camera. Yeah, yes, and. You know, you feed off an audience in theatre, I'm sure. And then when you're just in a room together and you've got a bunch of crew standing around you and you've got to create it for yourself. Otherwise, there's just a bunch of crew around you. Well, I know.
从事电影工作时，在镜头后或镜头前也是一样。是的，是的。你知道，你在剧院里从观众那里汲取能量，我相信。然后当你只是在一个房间里，周围有一群工作人员，你必须为自己创造它。否则，周围就只是一群工作人员。嗯，我知道。
Well, it is true that I can speak as the three of us, I've worked with both of these guys. And neither none of us, I've worked with both of these guys. And neither none of us really sort of come in prepared in the sense that we don't fully have it memorized a certain way. You can't. You have to kind of have a loose relationship with whatever you're doing, because so much of it is informed by what the other person is bringing sort of leave room for the effect of the other Yeah, yeah, like that's a But by the way, well, can I just really quick and then I look it off this J
嗯，确实，我可以代表我们三个人说话，我和这两个人都合作过。我们都没有，我和这两个人都合作过。我们都没有真正准备好，在这个意义上，我们没有完全以某种方式背下来。你不能。你必须对你正在做的任何事情保持一种松散的关系，因为其中很多是由另一个人带来的东西所影响的，给对方的效果留出空间。是的，是的，就像那是。但顺便说一句，好吧，我可以很快地说一下，然后我离开这个J
I'm gonna send you this song because it's one of the most famous songs It's such an old song it's called somebody, but you'll love it because and I love this because the dumb dumb didn't quite get it back then About the comment, you know, it's I to share, share the rest of my life, share my innermost thoughts, know my intimate details. Like it goes on and on, it's gorgeous lyrics about sharing your life with somebody. And the last lyrics at the end is,
我要发给你这首歌，因为它是最著名的歌曲之一，它是一首很老的歌，叫《Somebody》，但你会喜欢它，因为，我喜欢这个，因为那个傻瓜当时没完全明白关于评论的事，你知道，它是“分享，分享我余生的每一刻，分享我内心深处的想法，了解我亲密的细节。”就像它一直持续下去，这是关于与某人分享生活的华丽歌词。而最后的歌词是，
though things like this make me sick. In a case like this, I'll get away with it. Which completely obliterates the whole song. And like as a kid, I was like, wait a minute, I was about to cry. This is why. Because love is ballocks. That's why I love is ballocks. Yeah.
“尽管这样的事情让我恶心。在这种情况下，我会逃脱惩罚。”这完全抹杀了整首歌。就像小时候，我心想，等一下，我正要哭。这就是为什么。因为爱是废话。这就是为什么爱是废话。是的。
It still gets played at lots and lots of weddings. And I'm so nervous just having a laugh at everybody else's experience. So for a dummy music listener like me, I always struggle to hear what the words, what did they say? What did they know? Back it up, is it?
它仍然在很多很多婚礼上播放。我只是在嘲笑别人的经历。所以对于像我这样的音乐听众，我总是很难听清歌词，他们说了什么？他们知道什么？倒回去，是吗？
I'll screw it. I'll just listen to you. Martin, do you ever get, have you ever had a point where you've gone to Dave and you said, this is a beautiful line and I can't understand what you're saying. Annuncie more. Or don't just mumble that
去他的。我只听你的。Martin，你有没有过这样的时刻，你去找Dave说，这是一句美丽的歌词，但我听不懂你在说什么。吐字清楚点。或者不要只是嘟囔，
because it sounds best. Right? You're sort of missing this word structure that you're doing. It depends our drunk who are you saying. Right. There's that tipping point. We all know the tipping point. It's great.
因为它听起来最好。对吧？你有点错过了你正在做的这种词汇结构。取决于你喝了多少酒。对。有一个临界点。我们都知道那个临界点。它很棒。
And then it's not great anymore. You know, it's enough. Back in the day. We were lucky that we sorted something out before you actually had to do a guide book or in the studio because there was a track that didn't go on the album that's coming later in the year. And it's called Life 2.0. What did you think it was called, Dave?
然后它就不再棒了。你知道，够了。回到过去。我们很幸运，在我们必须在录音室做指南书之前就解决了某些事情，因为有一首没进专辑的歌，今年晚些时候会出。它叫《Life 2.0》。你以为它叫什么，Dave？
Oh, yeah. Oh, no. Life, what was it, Mark? I forgot. Life, life to... Life to... I have to do, do, do. No, life, what was it, Mark? I forgot. Life, life to, life to,
哦，是的。哦，不。Life，它叫什么，Martin？我忘了。Life，life to... Life to... 我必须做，做，做。不，life，它叫什么，Martin？我忘了。Life，life to，life to，
to perform or something. I don't know, life to. I think I even wrote it down. I wrote it down because when Mark sent me the song, he often doesn't send the words. He'll send a demo or whatever. And so I kinda listen. Life to prolong.
去表演之类的。我不知道，life to。我想我甚至把它写下来了。我把它写下来了，因为当Martin发给我这首歌时，他通常不发歌词。他会发一个小样之类的。所以我听了一下。Life to prolong。
Life to prolong. That was it. Life too prolonged, that was it. Life too prolonged, I was like, okay, all right. Life too prolonged, I don't think anyone's ever used the word prolonged in a song, that's pretty cool. Dave, when you're performing it later in the year, you've got to, or if you're performing it now on stage, you've got to get the audience going saying, that's too prolonged. That can happen.
Life to prolong。就是那个。Life too prolonged，就是那个。Life too prolonged，我心想，好吧，好吧。Life too prolonged，我不认为有人在歌里用过“prolonged”这个词，那很酷。Dave，当你今年晚些时候表演它时，你必须，或者如果你现在在舞台上表演它，你必须让观众跟着说，那太漫长了。那可能会发生。
I said the other night, let's go nicks, you know, because at the end of everything counts, I just shout out in the garden, let's go nicks. A lot of views. Oh, that must have gone big. Well, be right back. This episode is brought to you in part by 8 sleep. Did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality?
我前几天晚上说，让我们走吧，尼克斯，你知道，因为在《Everything Counts》的结尾，我只是在花园里大喊，让我们走吧，尼克斯。很多观点。哦，那一定很轰动。好吧，马上回来。本集部分由Eight Sleep赞助。你知道温度是提高睡眠质量最重要的因素之一吗？
Did you know that? Did you, be honest? I don't think you really did. Science, okay? Now you're paying attention. Science has shown that your body temp actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep.
你知道吗？你，老实说？我不认为你真的知道。科学，好吗？现在你注意到了。科学表明，你的体温实际上需要在睡眠的早期和中期下降，并在早上升高，这样你才能快速入睡并获得更多的深度睡眠。
So, why am I saying all this? Because the pod cover by 8 sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet. The pod cover will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed, based on you and your partner's individual needs. It can cool down and warm up and adjusts based on the phases of your sleep and the environment that you are in. Guys, talk about a revolution.
所以，我为什么要说这些？因为Eight Sleep的Pod Cover像床单一样适合任何床。Pod Cover将通过根据你和伴侣的个人需求自动调节床两侧的温度来改善你的睡眠。它可以降温和升温，并根据你的睡眠阶段和你所处的环境进行调节。伙计们，谈谈革命吧。
I just got my eight sleep pod cover just sent to me. Can I tell you something? I have been battling with heat issues with my sleep forever, trying to get that right temperature to fall asleep. I want it to be cool and then I get too hot but I'm so excited to snag in with my eight-sleep. I can't even tell you, I wish I could go to sleep right now. It's the middle of the day, but I'm just wait,
我刚收到Eight Sleep Pod Cover。我能告诉你一件事吗？我一直在与睡眠中的热量问题作斗争，试图找到合适的温度来入睡。我想要凉爽，然后我变得太热了，但我太兴奋了，想用我的Eight Sleep。我甚至无法告诉你，我真希望现在就能去睡觉。现在是中午，但我只是等，
I can't wait till tonight. I am gonna try it out and wait to you guys here. The result, they're gonna be amazing. While temperature is the biggest game changer, the pod cover has other amazing features. For example, thanks to the pod's sleep and health tracking, you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights on how certain behaviors
我等不及今晚了。我要试一试，等着你们听。结果，它们会很棒。虽然温度是最大的游戏规则改变者，但Pod Cover还有其他惊人的功能。例如，多亏了Pod的睡眠和健康追踪，你每天早上都可以醒来看到一份个性化的睡眠报告，提供关于某些行为如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康的见解，
like late night exercise or caffeine impact your sleep and overall health, invest in the rest you deserve with the eight sleep pod. Go to eight sleep.com slash smart list for exclusive Memorial Day savings on the pod cover through June 6th. Stay cool this summer with eight sleep. Now shipping within the USA, Canada,
比如深夜锻炼或咖啡因，投资于你应得的休息，使用Eight Sleep Pod。前往eightsleep.com/smartless，在6月6日前享受Pod Cover的独家阵亡将士纪念日优惠。今年夏天保持凉爽，使用Eight Sleep。现在在美国、加拿大、
the UK, select countries in the EU and Australia. Well, I'd be remiss if I didn't say that our next partner is athletic greens. First of all, let me just start by saying, I take AG1 by athletic greens literally every day. I gave AG1 to try. I'm gonna say it was about maybe just under two years ago because I kind of wanted to. I felt like it was missing something. I've never been like a huge supplement guy or doing any of that kind of stuff. But I thought, AG1, athletic greens, I sort of heard about it. I started doing it about, I don't know,
英国、欧盟部分国家和澳大利亚发货。好吧，如果我不说我们的下一个合作伙伴是Athletic Greens，我就失职了。首先，让我从说我真的每天都服用Athletic Greens的AG1开始。我试用了AG1。我想说大约是在不到两年前，因为我有点想。我觉得它缺少了什么。我从来不是那种超级补充剂爱好者，也不做那种事。但我心想，AG1，Athletic Greens，我听说过它。我开始服用大约，我不知道，
I maybe started taking it because of the show. There's a possibility that that's what happened. But whatever happened was, I started doing it and then the boys and Robin Bennett started doing it. And we all started noticing, first of all, I had better gut health. I felt more energized. And I knew that they'd said they could,
我可能是因为节目才开始服用的。有可能发生了这种情况。但无论发生了什么，我开始服用它，然后男孩们和Robin Bennett也开始服用它。我们都开始注意到，首先，我的肠道健康状况变好了。我感觉更有活力了。我知道他们说过他们可以，
like, you know, it would optimize my immune system, which that sounds good. Sounds better than not getting an optimized immune system. But I hated taking vitamins and all that stuff. Anyway, so I started doing it. It is the best option for easy optimal nutrition out there. You take one scoop of AG1 and you're absorbing 75 high quality vitamins, minerals, whole food source, superfoods,
就像，你知道，它会优化我的免疫系统，这听起来不错。听起来比没有优化的免疫系统要好。但我讨厌服用维生素和所有那些东西。总之，我开始服用它。它是目前最简单的最佳营养选择。你服用一勺AG1，你就能吸收75种高质量的维生素、矿物质、全食物来源的超级食物，
and probiotics and adaptogens to help you start your day right. And this blend of ingredients supports your gut health, your nervous system, your immune system, your energy, your recovery, focus, aging, all of that. I've just, for me, it's been such an unbelievably positive experience. I love, I love, you know, talking about, first of all, I annoy a lot of people with AG1 because everybody in my house, I'm like, why don't you try it?
以及益生菌和适应原，帮助你开启美好的一天。这种成分混合物支持你的肠道健康、神经系统、免疫系统、能量、恢复、专注、抗衰老，所有这些。对我来说，这是一种令人难以置信的积极体验。我喜欢，我喜欢，你知道，谈论，首先，我用AG1烦扰了很多人，因为我家里每个人，我都说，你为什么不试试？
I wanna get, Alessandra on it. I'm always talking. Bateman gets real annoyed. I mean, Bateman gets annoyed by pretty much everything because he's so cranky all the time. And maybe Jason would be a little less cranky if he'd just listen to me and take it every single day.
我想让Alessandra也用它。我一直在说。Bateman真的很烦。我是说，Bateman对几乎所有事情都感到烦恼，因为他总是那么暴躁。也许如果Jason能听我的话，每天服用它，他会少一点暴躁。
I bet you if you could look at the days he's cranky, those are the days that he missed taking AG1. And right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your body with convenient daily nutrition. It's just a scoop of AG1, one scoop in a cup of water every day, and you don't need a million different pills and supplements to look out at you. You know, all that stuff just to look out for your health. No, athletic greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune supporting vitamin
我敢打赌，如果你能看看他暴躁的日子，那些就是他错过服用AG1的日子。现在，是时候重获健康，用方便的日常营养武装你的身体了。每天只需一勺AG1，一杯水，你就不需要一百万种不同的药丸和补充剂来照顾自己。你知道，所有那些东西只是为了照顾你的健康。不，Athletic Greens将为你提供一年的免费免疫支持维生素
D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. Go to athleticgreens.com slash smartless to give AG1 a try. That's athleticgreens.com slash smartless. Get out! All right, back to the show. Did I hear you say that it got kind of craft work asked? Did you say yes? Yes.
D和五包免费旅行装，随你的首次购买。前往athleticgreens.com/smartless试用AG1。那是athleticgreens.com/smartless。滚开！好吧，回到节目。我听到你说它变得有点像Kraftwerk风格了？你说的是吗？是的。
It's so funny because you're like the third band that's referenced craft work and I was just listening to Tour de France this morning as well, which is such a, I love that tune. And I think it was Jay when you had the boys from... Radiohead were talking about craft work as well. Like it was just what an influential band these guys were. It's unbelievable. Well, they were probably instrumental in Martin getting a synth. I was really managing it in the first five. Really?
这太有趣了，因为你就像第三个提到Kraftwerk的乐队，我今天早上也在听《Tour de France》，那真是一首，我喜欢那首歌。我想是Jay，当你有来自……Radiohead的伙计们也在谈论Kraftwerk。就像这些家伙是一个多么有影响力的乐队。这令人难以置信。好吧，他们可能在Martin获得合成器方面起了作用。我真的在前五名里管理它。真的吗？
Yeah, and we were talking about the early bands that influenced us. We mentioned that wave that was coming up with us, but they were obviously way before that. You know, auto-barm was like 74. Yeah, yeah. Wow, man. I think Daniel was well. Daniel Miller, like, he sort of, once he's influenced,
是的，我们当时在谈论影响我们的早期乐队。我们提到了和我们一起兴起的那股浪潮，但他们显然在那之前很久。你知道，Autobahn是74年的。是的，是的。哇，伙计。我想Daniel也是。Daniel Miller，就像，他有点，一旦他受到影响，
he was listening to, you know, he's a little bit older than us. So there was like, noise, and there was all these, like, German kind of, those, that kind of stuff, Mark, that like, we wouldn't have probably heard, really, if it wasn't for him. And it's that sort of crowd rock that was called that stuff as well.
他在听，你知道，他比我们大一点。所以有像Noise，还有所有这些，像德国的那种，那种东西，Martin，如果我们不是因为他，可能真的不会听到。还有那种被称为Krautrock的东西。
A lot of like waiting for the 9-4, for instance, it's got that continuous kind of like rolling progression all the time. These influences definitely, okay. We were lucky to work with a lot of people, engineers, producers, people that were all on that cusp of well as well, of wanting to do something new with pop music.
很多像《Waiting for the 9-4》之类的，它一直有那种持续的滚动进程。这些影响绝对是，好吧。我们很幸运能与很多人合作，工程师、制作人，那些都在那个边缘的人，也一样，想要用流行音乐做一些新的事情。
Well, you guys also embody that too, Martin. That sort of, like you said, Dave, that progression. You guys understood the importance of it, that sort of drove so many of your songs. Atmosphere. Atmosphere, and it almost hypnotic, right? Atmosphere over a lot of other things that I'm sometimes, we would go round with like tight machines
马丁，你们也体现了这一点。就像你说的，戴夫，那种进步。你们理解它的重要性，这推动了你们的许多歌曲。氛围。氛围，几乎是催眠般的，对吧？氛围胜过其他许多东西，有时我们会带着像紧凑型机器一样的东西
into like scrap yards or building sites and record like weird shit noises that you heard. And then you'd hop. Everything counts has all that stuff at the start, right? Yeah, I don't even know what that was now. What was that? Like a store or something? Yeah, like a store or something. Like a store or something.
去废品场或建筑工地，录下你听到的那些奇怪的噪音。然后你会跳跃。Everything Counts 在开头就有所有这些东西，对吧？是的，我现在甚至不知道那是什么。那是什么？像商店之类的东西？是的，像商店之类的东西。像商店之类的东西。
That's the industrial. That was like a Chinese violin that was badly sold. Oh, yes. Yeah, that we couldn't play. It was an instrument that we couldn't play. That you just made a bit of a play. Jason was an issue that we couldn't play that you just might have been a big political. Jason, did you want to hear me say that again? Yeah, no, I think we got it.
那是工业风。那就像一把卖得不好的中国小提琴。哦，是的。是的，我们不会拉。那是一种我们不会演奏的乐器。你只是随便玩了一下。杰森，那是一个我们不会演奏的问题，你只是可能是一个大政治家。杰森，你想让我再说一遍吗？是的，不，我想我们明白了。
You guys are uniquely qualified to comment about where we find the music industry today. And are you guys a big fan or is it a love hate with what technology, digital and all that stuff has done as far as the way in which music is sold now a days and what that's done to the touring business and what not because you guys obviously have the best of both worlds. I mean, you're still playing Madison Square Garden and you're still selling albums. But so how does all that sit with you today's current makeup of the business. Sorry, and be honest. Yeah. I mean, we came up a good and bad, right? We came up a teens, I mean, it was like albums, vinyl, you know, getting that record, getting, you know, going to having enough money to go buy a 45 or a 7, you know, which was I think at the time when I first probably 45 P or whatever, like something like that. You know, to go, you know, stole it from somewhere and you got, you went to the market and you
你们非常有资格评论我们今天所处的音乐产业。你们是它的忠实粉丝，还是对科技、数字技术以及所有这些东西在当今音乐销售方式以及对巡演业务等方面所产生的影响又爱又恨？因为你们显然两全其美。我的意思是，你们仍然在麦迪逊广场花园演出，仍然在卖专辑。那么，你们今天如何看待这种商业构成？抱歉，请诚实回答。是的。我的意思是，我们经历了好的和坏的，对吧？我们是在青少年时期成长起来的，我的意思是，那是专辑、黑胶唱片的时代，你知道，得到那张唱片，有足够的钱去买一张45转或7英寸唱片，你知道，我想当时我第一次大概是45便士还是什么的。你知道，去，你知道，从某处偷来的，然后你去市场，你
look through the singles and looked at the covers and go, this one looks weird and interesting and go, well, what is this? Of course, we had one show in England, like this TV show called Top of the Pops, where you were on Thursday nights, or whatever you'd see music like Bowie, and Gary Glitter, and Slide, and T-Rex, and all these sort of 70s things,
翻看单曲，看着封面，心想，这张看起来很奇怪很有趣，然后想，这是什么？当然，我们在英国有一个节目，叫《Top of the Pops》，你在周四晚上看，或者无论什么时候，你会看到像鲍伊、加里·格里特、斯莱德、T-Rex，以及所有这些70年代的东西，
and rock-sea music. That was a thing, that was like, where you get lost in it, but I think the album, you know, the album, I know Martin does as well, we both still play albums and buy albums and stuff, but you know, and listen to music digitally too. There's something has been lost, of course, in that, the specialness of an album, you know, and how you listen to that,
还有摇滚乐。那是一回事，就像你沉浸其中的地方，但我认为专辑，你知道，专辑，我知道马丁也这么认为，我们俩仍然播放专辑和购买专辑之类的，但你知道，也会以数字方式听音乐。当然，在这一点上失去了一些东西，专辑的特殊性，你知道，以及你如何聆听它，
how you play one side and then turn it over, and you've got to actually make the effort, you know, to do something. Right, right. Yeah, yeah. I love that. Yeah, I remember that. It's just sitting in a room and putting a wreck, taking it out of the sleeve, and putting it on. Remember that? Mel of it, you know. It's brilliant. You'd have a cleaner, taking it out of the sleeve, and putting it on. Remember that? Melovate, you know. It's brilliant. You'd have a cleaner, you'd have the dust or the brush. The brush, you'd let it go around, and clean off the needle,
你如何播放一面然后翻过来，你必须真正付出努力，你知道，去做某事。对，对。是的，是的。我喜欢那样。是的，我记得。只是坐在房间里，放一张唱片，把它从封套里拿出来，然后放上去。记得吗？那种感觉，你知道。太棒了。你会有一个清洁器，把它从封套里拿出来，然后放上去。记得吗？那种感觉，你知道。太棒了。你会有一个清洁器，你会用灰尘刷或刷子。刷子，你会让它转动，清理针头，
and drop the needle on it, and sit there, and maybe you would have lyrics. Sometimes if a record came out, you were waiting for it, and it had lyrics, you were like, Yes, that was cool. That was so, I mean, the barwee stuff would like be like, I remember I stole from my friend Phil Gurry. I was around his house and he had my nose for a go.
然后把针头放上去，坐在那里，也许你会看歌词。有时如果一张唱片发行了，你在等它，它有歌词，你会觉得，太棒了，那很酷。那太，我的意思是，鲍伊的东西就像，我记得我从我朋友菲尔·格里那里偷来的。我在他家，他有我的鼻子去试。
And I was around his flat and he had the double live, David Live at the Philadelphia Tower album. And I opened it up and I saw that this lyrics sheet, like, let's leave, fell out. and I was just kind of like sitting there and he went off to the toilet or sang for a minute. And when he was gone, I took it, I folded it up and I shoved it in my jacket and I was like, stole it with a stole.
我在他的公寓里，他有那张双碟现场专辑《David Live at the Philadelphia Tower》。我打开它，看到那张歌词页，就像，掉出来了。我只是坐在那里，他去洗手间或唱了一会儿。当他离开时，我拿走了它，把它折起来塞进我的夹克里，我就像，偷了它。
I was still everything if it wasn't tied down, by the way. But I stole this and I got it home and I had the lyrics myself and everything. And the battle week later, it feels like, I know you stole my lyrics from like, you know, I didn't idea, but you know, that's how special it was to have something like, she couldn't look it up, you know. I had a roommate in college who was obsessed with albums
顺便说一句，如果没锁好的话，我什么都偷。但我偷了这个，我把它带回家，我自己有了歌词和所有东西。一周后，感觉就像，我知道你偷了我的歌词，你知道，我没主意，但你知道，拥有那样的东西是多么特别，你没法查到，你知道。我在大学有个室友，他痴迷于专辑
and I took his beta. What was that group, Beethoven, camper beta, Beethoven? Camper van Beethoven, let this kid in. Take this kid and head's bowling. Yeah, and I took that. I was really sitting in his room. We were listening to the album.
我拿了他的贝塔。那个组合是什么，贝多芬，露营贝塔，贝多芬？露营车贝多芬，让这个孩子进来。拿走这个孩子，头在保龄球。是的，我拿走了那个。我真的坐在他的房间里。我们在听那张专辑。
And I took the jacket and I was so hot. And I took the album jacket and I started fanning myself and completely bent the whole thing. And he never heard from me again. Oh, no. He wouldn't talk to me. Yeah. Yeah.
我拿了封套，我太热了。我拿了专辑封套，开始给自己扇风，结果把整个东西都弄弯了。他再也没理过我。哦，不。他不会跟我说话。是的。是的。
I remember how this is, I have so many like different record memories But the one that I remember when that first civil minds record came out and they did a clear record Do you remember that and they yeah, we have a red vinyl right now? Mimense more Do you really is it came out red file? Yes in red clear one as well There's a red one a hundred and's a red one, 100 and 90 grams. Like, yeah, it's cool.
我记得这是怎么回事，我有太多关于唱片的不同记忆，但我记得当第一张《Civil Minds》唱片出来时，他们做了一张透明唱片，你记得吗？他们，是的，我们现在有红色黑胶唱片？Mimense更多，你真的有吗？它是红色黑胶吗？是的，还有红色透明的。有一张红色的，190克。就像，是的，很酷。
It's really cool. Well, now I'm going to buy it because that guy would come full circle. So you have this record came out. By the way, I was just thinking about the video that I just saw also has sort of like, I guess religious, I mean, you guys are in a gutsy. Well, it's a bit camp, too.
真的很酷。好吧，现在我要去买它，因为那家伙会兜个圈子。所以你有这张唱片出来了。顺便说一句，我刚才在想我刚看到的那个视频，也有点像，我想是宗教的，我的意思是，你们在胆量里。嗯，也有点做作。
Come on, let's face it. I'm crawling around on my hands and knees in a grave. I'm sitting playing, I'm so thoughtfully his guitar. And I'm crawling around him. Like, yeah. Sniff the glove. Yes, so when Anton Corbin says to me, so Dave, I want you to, you know, get on hands and knees,
来吧，面对现实吧。我在坟墓里手脚并用地爬行。我坐着弹奏，我如此深思熟虑地弹着他的吉他。我在他周围爬行。就像，是的。闻闻手套。是的，所以当安东·寇班对我说，戴夫，我想让你，你知道，手脚并用，
Corbin graveyard on the floor, you know, this graveyard's just like set up in a studio, by the way, as well, of course. And it looks already very, very kind of like, as soon as we get there, we're like, this is, this looks like really, like somebody said this up. At least, as I know, I wanted to look kind of fake Dave and I was like okay So he's the only person that would get me to do something like that and I think we did about the dark
寇班墓地在地板上，你知道，这个墓地顺便说一句也是在摄影棚里搭建的。而且它看起来已经非常，非常像，我们一到那里，我们就想，这看起来真的很像，有人搭建了这个。至少，据我所知，我想让它看起来有点假，戴夫，我就想好吧。所以他是唯一能让我做那种事的人，我想我们做了大约黑暗
I'm crawling around. I'm surprised he didn't do that actually I'm the leash Yes, it's the only way we got away is because I'm the one calling around, of course. If we had some, you know, beautiful girl or guy to do that or something, we would be in big trouble now. Sure, I see. I have a question. How do you guys determine who sings what track?
我在爬行。我很惊讶他竟然没那样做，其实我是那个被拴着的人。是的，我们能逃脱的唯一原因是因为我是那个爬行的人，当然。如果我们有某个，你知道，漂亮的女孩或男孩来做那个或什么的，我们现在会有大麻烦。当然，我明白了。我有一个问题。你们怎么决定谁唱哪首歌？
It's kind of obvious sometimes. It's usually obvious. Just because of where we're the ranges or because. Yeah, I mean, well, just so with me on this album, I knew I thought to myself, you know, Martin, Martin would just be asking that so much better than me. You know, it's different. Is it we have a different a different tone, a different way we sing. But together, it's just unbelievable. I used to get bent out of shape a bit. I used to years ago, I wanted to sing everything
有时很明显。通常很明显。只是因为我们的音域或者因为。是的，我的意思是，嗯，就这张专辑而言，我知道我对自己说，你知道，马丁，马丁唱得肯定比我好得多。你知道，这不一样。是我们有不同的音色，不同的演唱方式。但在一起，简直不可思议。我过去常常有点钻牛角尖。我过去几年里，我想唱所有的歌
and I used to feel like it was, but my voice wasn't good enough and that's my mind, but to sing a couple of songs. I mean, always, yeah, that was back in the years ago, but now I don't. It was, you know. What it means you got to break on stage as well. Yeah, I get a break too.
我过去常常觉得，但我的声音不够好，那是我的想法，但唱几首歌。我的意思是，总是，是的，那是几年前的事了，但现在我不这样了。那是，你知道。这意味着你在舞台上也能休息。是的，我也能休息。
I can't, I'm just like, so two hours set, I plus, I mean, I need that 10 minutes or so in the middle to sort of get some oxygen. But isn't that funny? And I'll see this to all of us is all gentlemen over 50. Isn't that funny you get to this age? And you're like all the things that used to sort of, you take personally your bother, you're whatever. You got so stupid.
我不能，我只是，所以两小时的演出，加上，我的意思是，我需要在中间那10分钟左右来补充一些氧气。但这不是很滑稽吗？我会对我们所有人说，都是50岁以上的绅士。到了这个年纪不是很滑稽吗？你就像所有那些过去让你，你个人觉得困扰的，你的什么。你太蠢了。
You use this shit, it's so stupid. Yeah, I'd rather take the break. Yeah, I'd rather take the break. I'd take the break. personally your body or whatever now you're like Oh, fuck, Jesus shit, it's so stupid. Yeah, I'd rather take the break. I'd take the break. Yeah, I would take the break for sure. And now, what are you doing on your breaks nowadays? Like at the garden during your 10 minutes versus what you were doing 30, 40 years ago during your 10 minute break? Has that changed backstage?
你过去用这些狗屎，太蠢了。是的，我宁愿休息一下。是的，我宁愿休息一下。我会休息一下。个人觉得困扰或什么的，现在你就像，哦，该死，天哪，太蠢了。是的，我宁愿休息一下。我会休息一下。是的，我肯定会休息一下。那么，你们现在休息时在做什么？比如在花园演出那10分钟，和你30、40年前那10分钟休息时相比？后台有什么变化吗？
That's changed a lot. Because for Jason, Jason, for Jason and me, it's changed a lot. We don't produce any more. Yes, right. We're probably squeezing a nap. We're as back at the old days. Yeah, we would have been, we would have been, you know, looking for something to just get a little bit more electricity into that set, you know. Yeah.
变化很大。因为对于杰森，杰森，对于杰森和我来说，变化很大。我们不再制作了。是的，对吧。我们可能在挤时间打个盹。我们就像在过去的日子里。是的，我们会，我们会，你知道，寻找一些东西来给那场演出增加一点电力，你知道。是的。
Was that fun playing the garden that must have been? Oh, my God. It always is. It's the church in New York, isn't it? Sure. It's a... Oh, they must have gone. No, we've been lucky enough to play. There are a lot of times over the years.
在花园演出很有趣吗？那一定是的。哦，天哪。一直都是。那是纽约的教堂，不是吗？当然。这是一个……哦，他们一定去了。不，我们很幸运能演出。多年来有很多次。
It's always one of those gigs that you're... You know, it's the anticipation and everything about it. I was lucky enough this time as well. My daughter's band, Stella Rose, and the dead language. We got... They had them open for us. So it was, that's cool. The nepotism was out the charts, but I could. Yeah, good.
这总是那些让你……你知道，那种期待和关于它的一切。这次我也很幸运。我女儿的乐队，Stella Rose and the Dead Language。我们让……他们为我们开场。所以这很酷。裙带关系简直爆表，但我可以。是的，很好。
Give the shit off this, Neppel Baby. I don't give a fucking shit about the Neppel Baby. Yeah, so hot. You do it if you could too. By the way, here's the other thing, man. That is a great name for a bad. I know No, spell it like a spell runs in the dead like Dead languages fucking great
把这东西拿走，裙带宝贝。我他妈的一点也不在乎裙带宝贝。是的，太火了。如果你能的话，你也会这么做。顺便说一句，还有一件事，伙计。那是一个很棒的乐队名字。我知道，不，拼写就像拼写运行在死像死语言一样，他妈的太棒了。
You know, they're pretty cool to they're like they're like way cooler than us But we were the headline in acts so yeah Because it's me I have to ask you have you ever been approached or would you ever do From the ground up with new songs brought by musical we did it we did get asked one somebody had this idea And they showed us a script, but it was all about like a bunch of heroin at it 5 6 7 8 So you know, we politely turned it down We're not it. 5, 6, 7, 8. So, you know, we politely turned it down. Jason and I would like to, and Sean's going to, you know, obviously going to run it, going
你知道，他们也很酷，他们就像，他们比我们酷多了。但我们是头牌艺人，所以是的。因为是我，我必须问你，你有没有被接触过，或者你会不会做从零开始的新歌音乐剧？我们确实被问过，有人有这个想法，他们给我们看了剧本，但全是关于一群海洛因成瘾者，5、6、7、8。所以你知道，我们礼貌地拒绝了。5、6、7、8。所以你知道，我们礼貌地拒绝了。杰森和我想，肖恩会，你知道，显然会去运行它，去
to direct and stuff, and it's about a bunch of middle eight white guy golfers. You got something there for sure. You don't have to think that. I just want to say before we let you guys go, because this has been absolutely mind-blowingly incredible. Sean, and this is really Sean to you. What would you say, Sean, can you believe that the college is you? You guys, I can't even describe it.
去导演之类的，它是关于一群中年白人高尔夫球手。你肯定有东西在那里。你不必那样想。在让你走之前，我只想说，因为这绝对是令人难以置信的。肖恩，这真的是肖恩对你说的。你会说什么，肖恩，你能相信那是大学的你吗？你们，我甚至无法描述。
I have to tell you guys right now to your faces, this is the Honest of God Truth. I'm doing a show here in New York, Broadway show. And every day that I walk to the theater, sometimes I get a ride, sometimes I walk, every time I walk, I listen to you guys. I literally, as I'm walking, I'll go, hey, Siri, play the pesh-node, I'm on my eye.
我现在必须当面告诉你们，这是上帝的诚实真相。我在这里，在纽约，百老汇演出。每天我走到剧院，有时我坐车，有时我走路，每次我走路，我都听你们的。我真的，当我走路时，我会说，嘿，Siri，播放Depeche Mode，我在我的眼睛里。
And tell the Broadway show is about a heroin addict. Anybody? Yeah, that's a true story, though, you guys are. And I want to say this before you leave, such a massive, massive influence on me and my life in such a huge way, just incredible. That's all I can say. That's very close. That's like it was so much.
告诉百老汇演出是关于一个海洛因成瘾者的。有人吗？是的，那是一个真实的故事，虽然，你们是。在你们离开之前，我想说，对我的人生有如此巨大、巨大的影响，以如此巨大的方式，简直不可思议。这就是我能说的。那非常接近。那就像它太多了。
The poster is up in college and the concerts I've been to to see you guys, it's just everywhere. It's just I can't, I can't, I can't go. I mean, there's a cool thing about what we get to do that we we get to do is that over the years that we get to hear from somebody like you or you know other artists have a musician's and stuff where what we've done somehow is influenced like them to do what they do yeah and you know this is this is how it goes around. And that's a, I think, an amazing thing about music and film and stuff like that, how it can, you know,
海报贴在大学里，我去看你们的演唱会，到处都是。我只是，我不能，我不能，我不能去。我的意思是，关于我们能做的事情有一件很酷的事，我们能做的是，多年来我们能听到像你这样的人，或者你知道其他艺术家有音乐家之类的，我们所做的某种程度上影响了他们去做他们所做的事情，是的，你知道，这就是它的循环方式。而且我认为这是关于音乐和电影之类的令人惊奇的事情，它如何能，你知道，
come be the soundtrack to our lives. For a while. I mean, it's inside of my DNA now. And when you guys just popped on screen, you're like, shh. Shaking. Yeah. And Sean, I mean, you, I was gonna say was,
成为我们生活的配乐。有一段时间。我的意思是，它现在在我的DNA里。当你们出现在屏幕上时，你们就像，嘘。颤抖。是的。肖恩，我的意思是，你，我本来想说的是，
what would college, Sean Hayes, say to was gonna say was, what would, what would college, Sean Hayes say to this moment? Like, what would you know? Well, I would be an idiot and be so over the top and trying to be funny and then you guys would be like, that guy's too much and then you would move on. We were probably to let you hang out. That's like, we're probably not to hang out. If he was entertaining for a bit,
大学里的肖恩·海耶斯会对这个时刻说什么？就像，你会知道吗？嗯，我会是个白痴，表现得太夸张，试图搞笑，然后你们会说，那家伙太过分了，然后你们就会继续。我们可能会让你待着。那就像，我们可能不会待着。如果他有一会儿很有趣，
you would've been having about a bit as being kind. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you've been the soundtrack to so many millions of people's lives and you're both such great guys on top of it all. What an absolute pleasure and honor to be both of you. And congratulations on the new record of the tour.
你会有一点点作为一种善意。是的。是的。好吧，你们一直是数百万人的生活配乐，而且你们俩都是很棒的人。能见到你们俩真是绝对的荣幸和荣幸。祝贺新唱片和巡演。
I really want to come and see you guys. Yeah. Are you in LA in September, right? We're coming. We just finished a little run in the States, but we're coming back, yeah, I think September October, October and November December, we're in, we're doing a much bigger North American too. We're off to Europe.
我真的很想去看你们。是的。你们九月在洛杉矶，对吧？我们要来了。我们刚在美国完成了一小段巡演，但我们要回来了，是的，我想九月十月，十月和十一月十二月，我们在，我们在做一次更大的北美巡演。我们要去欧洲。
We're going to come and see you guys. Oh please. Yeah, you know, thanks for having us on your show. It's really, yeah, thank you, thanks for having us on your show. It's really yeah, thank you Yeah, this has been a dream come true Yeah, yeah, honestly all all three of you in some way shape a form also have been in my life So I could say that we apologize and you we don't always have to say that honestly as well You know, but I mean that's it his really thank you. It's very nice
我们要去见你们。哦，请。是的，你知道，谢谢你们邀请我们上你们的节目。真的，是的，谢谢，谢谢你们邀请我们上你们的节目。真的，是的，谢谢。是的，这真是梦想成真。是的，是的，老实说，你们三个人以某种形式也一直在我生活中。所以我可以说我们道歉，你，我们不必总是那样说，老实说也是。你知道，但我的意思是，就是这样，真的谢谢。非常好。
If you guys can do this podcast for all the best of us. Thank you. You on the road I see you guys My god, well are you guys all right? I was really honestly truly shaking. Like I haven't done that. Sean, are you sitting on plastic? Did you lay down some plastic? Scotty just under under frame lay down some plastic for you. That's why Scotty came in at the middle. Yeah. I mean, not since the Michael Jackson concert 1983
如果你们能为我们所有人做这个播客，最好不过了。谢谢。你在路上，我见到你们。天哪，你们还好吗？我真的老实说真的在颤抖。就像我没做过那样。肖恩，你坐在塑料上吗？你铺了塑料吗？斯科蒂就在框架下，为你铺了塑料。这就是为什么斯科蒂在中间进来的原因。是的。我的意思是，自从1983年迈克尔·杰克逊演唱会以来
was I shaking. Oh my god. I mean, they really, I really honestly swear to God, listen to them every day. No, I know. That's crazy. I know. That's crazy. I know, that's unbelievable. Why is that, is that something that kind of
我就没颤抖过。哦，天哪。我的意思是，他们真的，我真的老实说对上帝发誓，每天都听他们。不，我知道。那太疯狂了。我知道。那太疯狂了。我知道，那令人难以置信。为什么会这样，那是某种
gets you going for the show? I think a lot of, I don't wanna bring this up, but I think a lot of like, they have a big gay following. And I think because it was, they were cool and underground and like, left of center and they weren't like machismo, hard, big hair rock and you know, dude. Yeah, there was something kind of interestingly glam about them.
让你为演出做好准备的东西吗？我想很多，我不想提起这个，但我认为很多，就像，他们有很多同性恋粉丝。而且我认为因为它是，他们很酷，很地下，就像，左倾，他们不像大男子主义、硬核、大头发摇滚，你知道，伙计。是的，他们身上有一种很有趣的华丽感。
I kind of like Bowie was beforehand. Yeah, Sean, I get that. I think it's not a gay straight thing or anything. It's just, I had a lot of gay friends in college that we found this band and we're like, oh, they're so cool. I think I know what you mean. And there were some bands that sort of came,
我有点像鲍伊之前那样。是的，肖恩，我明白了。我认为这不是同性恋异性恋的问题。只是，我在大学里有很多同性恋朋友，我们发现了这个乐队，我们就像，哦，他们太酷了。我想我知道你的意思。而且有一些乐队某种程度上来了，
but certainly a ratio were a band that were big and gay culture back in the 80s. Right, because I guess a lot of the Peshmoan songs were turned into dance songs and they would play them in the clubs. Oh, that's a good idea. And so I think that the personal Jesus, every one of those personal Jesus,
但Erasure肯定是一个在80年代同性恋文化中很大的乐队。对，因为我想很多Depeche Mode的歌被变成了舞曲，他们会在俱乐部里播放它们。哦，那是个好主意。所以我认为Personal Jesus，每一首那些Personal Jesus，
and you know, all those earlier songs, they have a beat that you can dance to. And so they turn those into club mixes. And I think that's probably one of the reasons for like, oh, what's this band? It's so cool. Plus they were like, dark. Wouldn't it be funny if I got a personal assistant
还有你知道，所有那些早期的歌，它们有一个你可以跳舞的节拍。所以他们把那些变成了俱乐部混音版。所以我认为这可能是像，哦，这是什么乐队？太酷了。加上他们就像，黑暗。如果我有一个私人助理不是很滑稽吗
named Jesus? No. Why would that be funny? Because then I'd have a personalus. No. Why would that be funny? Because then I'd have a personal Hazus. Oh. Wow, I'm slow today. It's a long walk around the block, but boy, the address is nice. Is that what you're talking about?
叫耶稣？不。那为什么会滑稽？因为那样我就有一个私人助手了。不。那为什么会滑稽？因为那样我就有一个私人助手了。哦。哇，我今天反应慢。绕着街区走了一大圈，但男孩，地址很好。这就是你在说的吗？
But just blown away. So, in the first, they're a huge part of my life, yeah. Yeah. I say, I have so many, it's kind of like when we've had other, but for these guys, I have those markers in my mind of where I was when that came out. Just can't get enough personal Jesus, blasphemous rumors. All those things. People are people.
但只是被震撼了。所以，在第一张，他们是我生命中重要的一部分，是的。是的。我说，我有太多，这有点像当我们有其他，但对于这些人，我的脑海里有那些标记，当那个出来时我在哪里。Just Can't Get Enough, Personal Jesus, Blasphemous Rumours。所有那些东西。People Are People。
Just like, you know, yeah. Jay, you would know like, no, all those you just mentioned, you know. Yeah. Jay, you would know like, No, all those you just mentioned, I know. Yeah. No, I'm very, very aware of the Pesh mode. I just, I wasn't, I didn't have the glow stick in my teeth. Like you did Sean and well, you know, I just fucking like, How was I supposed to find my way home?
就像，你知道，是的。杰伊，你会知道就像，不，所有你刚才提到的，你知道。是的。杰伊，你会知道就像，不，所有你刚才提到的，我知道。是的。不，我非常，非常了解Depeche Mode。我只是，我没有，我没有像你那样在牙齿里叼着荧光棒，肖恩，嗯，你知道，我只是他妈的喜欢，我该怎么找到回家的路？
Just, you know, you know. You know, but you, you can't believe before Jason really got into classical music, you'd get in his car with him. I'm not kidding. And the fucking music that Jason would listen to. I know something. It would be so random, not necessarily bad, but it would be like random and some would be brutal.
只是，你知道，你知道。你知道，但在杰森真正迷上古典音乐之前，你会和他一起上车。我不是在开玩笑。杰森会听的那种他妈的音乐。我知道一些。那会非常随机，不一定很糟糕，但它会很随机，有些会很残酷。
Yeah. By the way, I got into it with a woman on Instagram about two months ago, Sean, maybe I told you, because she was saying, it's actually, you're thinking of Yazoo, it's not Yazoo. And I said, no, in North America, Yazoo was called Yaz for legal reasons. And I had to school her because I was like, don't fucking correct me. Anyway, what was ourselves big hit? So painted love. Tainted love. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I listened to that too. And I love classic rock, but I also loved so much of the, I loved Bronsky beat. I love, you know, I can just loved it so much. I loved all those bands.
是的。顺便说一句，大约两个月前，我和一个女人在Instagram上吵了一架，肖恩，也许我告诉过你，因为她说，实际上，你在想Yazoo，不是Yazoo。我说，不，在北美，出于法律原因，Yazoo被称为Yaz。我不得不教育她，因为我当时想，别他妈纠正我。无论如何，我们的大热门是什么？所以Tainted Love。Tainted Love。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。我听了那个。我喜欢经典摇滚，但我也非常喜欢，我喜欢Bronski Beat。我喜欢，你知道，我只是太喜欢了。我喜欢所有那些乐队。
I loved them, of course, the Pesh mode. I don't know. Hey. But you know, like when they first came on, I was looking. Here we go. Boy, man. I tell you something, you know what it is. It's a look in your eye and you kind of take a breath when you're looking.
我喜欢他们，当然，Depeche Mode。我不知道。嘿。但你知道，就像他们刚出来时，我在看。我们走吧。男孩，伙计。我告诉你一件事，你知道那是什么。那是你眼中的神情，当你看着时，你会屏住呼吸。
No, it's a thank God. Thank God I had my glasses on when they came on because I couldn't believe my eyes. So I thank God I saw them with my reading part of my lower glasses, which is sometimes called, called, what's your glasses called? Don't go up high. Bye. Bo-bo-bo. Bye.
不，那是谢天谢地。谢天谢地，当他们出来时我戴着眼镜，因为我不敢相信我的眼睛。所以我谢天谢地，我用我眼镜下部的阅读部分看到了他们，有时被称为，被称为，你的眼镜叫什么？不要往高处走。再见。波波波。再见。
That's a depeche mode version of goodbye. Don't go up high. Bye. Vocal. If I can pass. Bye. That's a Dopech mode version of goodbye. Right? It's Martin taking it left instead of right. That's right. Bye. Vocals.
那是Depeche Mode版本的再见。不要往高处走。再见。声乐。如果我能通过。再见。那是Depeche Mode版本的再见。对吧？那是马丁向左而不是向右。没错。再见。声乐。
Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Blast. Smartness is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granterry. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Celebrity Beef, you never know if you're just going to end up on TMZ or trending on Twitter
再见。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。Blast。Smartness是100%有机的，由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Granterry手工制作。我们的下一集将在下周在任何你听播客的地方发布，或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过在Apple Podcasts或Wondry应用程序中订阅Wondry Plus提前且无广告收听。Celebrity Beef，你永远不知道你是否会最终出现在TMZ或Twitter趋势上
or in court. I'm Matt Bellasive And I'm Sydney Battle, and we're the host of Wonder E's new podcast, Dis and Tell. Each episode explores a different iconic celebrity feud, from the build-up, why it happened, and the repercussions. What does our obsession with these feuds say about us? We're starting off with a pretty messy love triangle between Selena Gomez and Justin and Haley Bieber, a seemingly innocent TikTok of Selena talking about her laminated eyebrows.
或在法庭上。我是Matt Bellasive，我是Sydney Battle，我们是Wondry新播客Dis and Tell的主持人。每一集探讨一个不同的标志性名人恩怨，从酝酿、为什么发生，到后果。我们对这些恩怨的痴迷说明了我们什么？我们从Selena Gomez、Justin和Hailey Bieber之间一个相当混乱的三角恋开始，一个Selena谈论她层压眉毛的看似无辜的TikTok。
It's snowballed into a full-blown alleged feud. But it doesn't seem like fans are letting up anytime soon. Despite both Selena and the Bieber's making public statements denying any bad blood. How much of this is teen jealousy and lovers quarreling, and how much of it is a carefully crafted narrative designed to sell albums? Follow Disantel wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wonder Yeah. Amazon Music or Wondering app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它滚雪球成了一场全面的所谓恩怨。但粉丝们似乎并没有很快放手。尽管Selena和Biebers都发表了公开声明否认任何不和。这其中有多少是青少年嫉妒和恋人争吵，又有多少是精心设计的旨在销售专辑的叙事？在任何你获取播客的地方关注Dis and Tell。你可以在Amazon Music或Wondry应用程序上无广告收听。是的。Amazon Music或Wondry应用程序。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。